Morka W.
Pogos. Pogu!
Massive.
Pogu.
So ein dummes Wort, oder?
Vor allem niemand in der echten Welt versteht das.
Geht mal zu irgendjemand auf der Straße und sagt Pogu.
Der denkt es ist irgendeine Beleidigung in einer anderen Sprache.
Hört sich auch so ein bisschen an, oder?
Wenn du es zu einem sagst Pogu.
Der denkt es heißt irgendwie Wichser oder so auf frag mich nicht Arabisch oder so.
In Frankfurt haut er dir aufs Maul direkt und du sagst Pogu.
Pogu, Alter.
Naja.
Lul.
Substance.
Massive.
Subscriptions.
Die Abo-Falle ist halt zugeschnappt.
Ich muss mal kurz in meine Mails gucken.
Vergess ich nämlich immer.
Und übersehe ich da manchmal Dinger drin wie...
...dass ich zum Beispiel endlich mal mein Steuerzeug fertig machen muss.
Your Amazon Order.
Aha, aha.
Wisst ihr was ich geordert habe Leute über Amazon?
Na gut ich hab's auf Twitter gepostet.
Ähm.
Wo ist das Gehäuse?
Amazon?
Ah, da ist das Gehäuse.
Ok, das Gehäuse kommt ein bisschen später.
Ja, ich hab den neuen PC bestellt.
Bis auf zwei Sachen.
Da weiß ich...
Krass, ich kauf mir doch keinen fertigen Alienware PC oder so ein Crap.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das wird selbst zusammengebaut.
Es ist mehr oder weniger...
...ziemlich genau dieser PC geworden.
Aber nicht ganz.
Nicht ganz.
Zeigt mal hier.
Wunschliste.
Moment.
Haben wir das vielleicht hier gemacht?
Geizhals.
Wunschlisten.
Omega Lul.
Ja.
Also es ist mehr oder weniger der PC geworden.
Aber nicht ganz.
Nicht ganz.
Ja das Bankkonto glüht durch.
So 4600 Euro hat es gekostet.
Also.
Die Grafikkarte ist es nicht geworden.
Sondern es ist...
Ich kann das ja gerade mal aktualisieren.
Wenn wir schon dabei sind kann ich das gerade mal aktualisieren.
Es ist nicht die Grafikkarte geworden.
Sondern es ist...
Diese Grafikkarte geworden.
Einfach weil die ein bisschen günstiger ist.
Beziehungsweise auch gerade lieferbar.
Letztendlich nimmt sich das ja alles nicht wirklich viel.
So es ist diese Grafikkarte geworden.
Und...
Es ist...
Leute, ihr werdet es nicht glauben.
Ich wusste mal kurz den Lüfter wegmachen.
Nein, nicht den Lüfter.
Die Wassergut.
Das ist ein RGB-Kühler geworden.
Ist das Ding geworden.
Nicht so ganz.
420A RGB.
Ja.
Es ist das Ding geworden mit RGB.
So.
Jetzt kommen wir der Sache schon relativ nah.
Mach mal den Shared Link.
Dann können wir das in den Bot packen.
Ja, das ist eine gute Idee.
Aber erstmal.
Mir fehlen noch zwei Sachen.
Und da müsst ihr mir mal helfen bei.
Und so habe ich alles bestellt.
Also Geld ausgegeben habe ich schon.
Die anderen Sachen sind nicht so teuer.
Aber da müssen wir gerade noch mal kurz gucken.
Also das ist eigentlich relativ...
Ach so.
Die Festplatte machen wir noch rein.
14 TB HDD.
Es ist eine...
Sieg...
Ne.
Irgendwas mit Helium drinne.
Oder sowas.
Heißt es Helium?
So was in der Richtung ist das.
Irgendwas in der Richtung.
Irgendwas ungefähr.
Ich muss mal kurz auf die Festplatte gucken.
Es ist...
Es ist quasi sowas hier.
Es plus keine Eienwulfe.
Es ist eine Skyhawk oder sowas.
Die hatte ich im Nass drinne früher.
Aber...
Packen wir die jetzt einfach mal rein.
Das nimmt sich alles nicht so viel.
So zur Wunschliste hinzufügen.
Omega Lul.
Alles klar.
So.
Ähm.
Mr.
Hammer, ich danke schon für den Sub.
Habe ich schon gesagt.
Aber egal.
Kann man nicht oft genug sagen.
Richtig Naisu.
Ein random YouTube Viewer hier.
Braucht man für eine 5800X eine Wasserkühlung?
Du brauchst eigentlich für nichts eine Wasserkühlung.
Äh.
Für...
Das ist doch...
Das ist letzte Generat...
Quatsch.
Da brauchst du keine Wasserkühlung.
Du brauchst...
Du brauchst für nichts wirklich eine Wasserkühlung.
Warum ich eine Wasserkühlung habe ist folgendes.
Die neuen CPU-Generationen werden unglaublich heiß.
Auch nur unter nicht-Gaming-Bedingungen.
Wenn jetzt irgendwie irgendein Benchmark laufen lässt.
Oder so.
Irgendein CPU-Benchmark oder so.
Dann kratzen die immer an 100 Grad.
Und so kriegt man halt vielleicht noch ein paar Taktraten mehr raus.
Ja.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Ich wollte einfach mal eine Wasserkühlung haben.
Und dementsprechend habe ich halt auch das fette Gehäuse gekauft.
Wo es reinpasst.
Fertig aus.
Wichtig.
Massive Subscription hier wieder.
Huge.
Naisu.
Massive Subscriptions.
So.
Also.
Das ist richtig.
Was ich hier eingetragen habe.
Soweit.
So gut.
Das stimmt auch alles.
Meshify 2 XL.
Das stimmt auch.
So.
Das einzige was mir jetzt noch fehlt Leute ist.
Der RAM.
Der ist übrigens ja auch noch nicht dabei.
Wie man gerade sieht.
Der RAM fehlt noch.
Ist ja teuer genug.
Weil abgesehen davon die Platte habe ich noch.
Die können wir eigentlich wieder abziehen vom Preis.
Aber ich mache es jetzt nochmal rein.
Weil es halt eben der PC ist.
Also.
Den RAM.
Leute ihr müsst mir da mal helfen.
Was RAM Ausstattung für neuen PC angeht.
Netzteil.
Netzteil brauche ich übrigens auch noch.
Also ich habe nur zwei Sachen noch nicht bestellt.
Das ist Netzteil und RAM.
Ist aber kein großartiges Problem.
Weil Netzteil und RAM kriegst du eigentlich immer.
Ist auch wunderbar lieferbar.
Also hab kein Problem.
Ich kann euch ja mal zeigen was aufs Mainboard drauf passt.
Was bei NBB.
Was ist das Notebooks billiger.
Zeigt mal hier.
Ein Schnapper.
Gaming.
Soll ich mal einfach nach RTX 4090 suchen findet man dann was?
Ich blick bei denen ihrer Seite immer nicht durch.
Grafikkarten.
Nee.
Gaming.
Gaming Hardware.
Die Webseite ist pepega.
4000er Serie.
4090.
Nee.
Das war wohl nix.
Da kann man nur sagen, ich find man im Ordentlich.
Schnell ausverkauft.
Ja.
Also wie gesagt ich hab das Ding jetzt bestellt hier.
Kostet ja, komm die 200 Euro mehr machen es ehrlich gesagt bei dem fetten Preis jetzt
auch nicht.
Nicht fett.
Ja.
Richtig Pogu das du regelmäßig triffst.
Pogu.
Wie gesagt ich hab gerade gesagt Pogu hört sich fast wie eine Beleidigung an.
Du Pogu alter.
So.
Also sag mir mal was für ein Ram soll ich mir kaufen.
Ich.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher inwieweit also bei AMD System war es ja lange Zeit so das
Ram Geschwindigkeit extrem viel ausgemacht hat der DDR5 auf jeden Fall aber ich bin mir
nicht ganz sicher.
Also die 0815 Geschwindigkeit sind 5600 das weiß ich 5600.
Wieso ja ganz ehrlich it's Gamer weiß ich nicht ich hab das einfach noch drinnen ich
hab noch kein Netzteil gekauft ich hab weder Netzteil gekauft noch Ram alles andere hab
ich.
Also die Preis Frage ist halt lohnt sich 6400er Ram überhaupt versus 5600 ich meine das kostet
schon immer 400€ mehr ne 300€ mehr oder so gibt es da irgendwelche irgendwelche Vergleiche
ich meine ok gucken wir mal was QVL was soll das sein Ram achso die vendor Liste vom Hersteller
jaja die Benchmark von den Herstellern sind auch mit 6000er gemacht also ich will 64G
ich will 64G 2 Riegel am besten ja also sagen wir mal KIT KIT Größe ab 64G gibt es ja nicht
so viel zur Auswahl ne gibt es ja nicht so viel zur Auswahl ne also ist jetzt ja nicht
so als gibt es so viel zur Auswahl gerade es gibt die gleichen einmal in schwarz und
einmal in weiß alternativ wenn man sich das hier mal anguckt 32 nehmen wir mal 32 GIG Einzelmodulgröße
32 GIG also da bleibt nicht so viel ja wir schauen mal wir schauen mal gerade mal just
for fun wie ist es bei 5006 oder gibt es nämlich eine ganze Ecke mehr das ist halt das macht
halt das macht halt preislich was aus ja das macht halt 200€ aus ungefähr der Ram wobei
man halt auch ehrlich sagen muss drauf geschissen eigentlich bei dem preis ja gut 4 Module wären
günstiger aber ich habe lieber 2 Module als 4 Module letztendlich macht es ja keinen großen
Unterschied was hast du so was hast du vor mit so viel RAM siehst du nicht wie viele
Tabs ich offen habe und da auch noch mal und dann habe ich noch eine 4M meistens offen die
hat auch RAM die hat auch Tabs und braucht RAM also 32 GIG kriege ich manchmal voll oh guck mal
wenn ich die 4M starte da geht ein bisschen was Leute und wenn ich mit der mit der ein bisschen
was gemacht haben mit der 4M dann sind wir also wir haben ja oftmals auch mehrere 4M offen
dann sind wir schon mal also ich habe ich ich schaffe es manchmal an 32 GIG Auslastung ran
also 64 G werden schon nice letztendlich machen sie 200€ mehr doch jetzt anders aus bei der
ganzen geschichte außerdem ist es RGB RAM komm sehen wir mal zur Wunschliste hinzufügen
omega lul so kein rgb ja ich habe gesagt der rechner bekommt kein rgb aber ich habe mir
das mal angeguckt und festgestellt mainboard hat standardmäßig rgb drauf grafika hat
standardmäßig auch rgb drauf der die wasserkühlung hat für zwei euro auf preis rgb drauf und
ja gut ob der ram jetzt rgb hat oder nicht ist mir eigentlich ziemlich egal
ich habe den csonic netzteil noch übrig aber das hat 650 watt das kann ich nicht verwenden
ja und die letzte frage ist halt was für ein netzteil leute realistisch betrachtet
ich mache die ich mache die disk raus die habe ich schon und dann sieht es nicht ganz
so krass teuer aus hast du nicht schon einen guten nee was für eine wasserkühlung die
hier ich habe einen guten pc der ist aber 5 jahre alt so und das letzte was ich brauche
ist ein netzteil tatsächlich brauche netzteil ich weiß noch nicht welche sich kaufen soll
also also 1000 sollten es wahrscheinlich sein bei der kombination spricht was dagegen auf
den 7900 x zu warten moment wo steht das an die xt ich habe keine ahnung er nicht amt
hat sehr geringe schäher hoffe ich hoffe ganz ehrlich ich hoffe wirklich darauf dass
die neue gpu generation von amd extrem erfolgreich wird weil die preise die nvidia verlangen
sehen ja echt jenseits von von gut und böse da gibt es nicht so viele und die dies gibt
und vor allem die die lieferbar sind sind nicht so geil das ist speziellen grund naja
wirklich nur weil ich war ein rechner haben will mit wasserkühlung ist das für musik
schon besser also wie gesagt was das
kohling habe ich noch nie gehört wir sollten leute was haltet davon ich glaube lc power
soll gute netzteile herstellen oder lc power soll ich mal gucken lc power 1000 watt netzteil
aliexpress ok wir schauen mal 1000 watt power supply
hier das gute 77 euro tf skywind intel 1000 watt bergbau da bin ich ja froh dass das für
den bergbau geeignet ist freundliche erinnerung alle unsere produkte haben garantiert und garantie
das ist ja nice hauptsache was cool wäre wenn es garantierte garantie hätte ja ja mining
ist bergbau oh gott aliexpress gehen wir fort also das letzte was ich mir kaufen würde für
den rechner ist ein aliexpress filter ab herstell garantie tatsächlich das ist mir noch nie
aufgefallen ja hier gibt es leider nicht so viele was 16 pin pce 2x 16 pin pce ja die
sind leider alle nicht so gut gewesen ich habe mir ein paar tests durchgelesen zu atx3 netzteilen
die waren nicht so geil naja intertech oder cooler master also ganz ehrlich ich würde
entweder einen seasonic nehmen oder einen be quiet und fertig so was hier zum beispiel
das seasonic prime tx hat über 400 euro nähe also 400 euro gebe ich nicht für also ich
meine das macht es bei den pc jetzt alles nicht fett aber es muss ja muss es ja nicht
übertreiben sagen wir jetzt das ein rgb netzteil oder was um so weil es 2000 watt kostet wollte
keine sache
so
Guck mal was es da gibt aber ich hatte ich genau die hatte ich mir schon angeguckt die
waren alle nicht so geil die waren alle nicht so geil die ganzen atx 3 und dings also erstens
waren sie teuer also da kann also es noch so sehr rocken also irgendwann irgendwann ist auch mal
gut ja ne das kaufe ich nicht warum nehme ich nicht einfach in den be quiet wieder also ich
hatte die letzten jahre eigentlich nur so gut so gut wie immer be quiet oder sieh sonic warum
nehme ich nicht warum nehme ich nicht einfach so ein ding hier guck hier da beim sowas da be
quiet dark power 12 zum beispiel einfach sowas oder was ist eine unterschied hier zwischen
machen wir machen mal kurz wir kompären das was war eine liste lernen bestätigen weg wir
kompären das mal kurz so also lüfter gut passt eh alles rein ja das ist ein bisschen wie
welche formfaktor die dinger sind oder so also was ist was ist hier der unterschied großartig
anschlüsse 11 mal sata niemand braucht 11 11 leute 11 mal sata gut es ist modular du musst
es ja nicht anstecken wenn das nicht passt 11 mal sata idee wait a minute was es gibt keine
idee stromstecker das sind diese ganz normalen molex stecker was soll denn idee was soll dann
ein idee stromstecker es gibt keine idee stromstecker das waren diese ganz normalen vier pin molex
stinger wahrscheinlich meinen die das kann man die sortieren mal nach was rechtfertigt
denn diesen krassen preis dahinten es hat eine platinum wertung das reicht ja ehrlich
gesagt okay das hat eine titanium wertung aber also mal ganz im ernst den strom bis
du den eingespart hast um einfach doppelt so tolles netzteil zu rechtfertigen ergibt
ja keinen sinn das ist einfach nur 150 volt anstatt 230 nee wat wehn juckts
ganz im ernst ich kann einfach das billigste netzteil nehmen oder also von denen hier was
brauche ich was brauche ich bei dem anderen also was ist hier zum beispiel der unterschied
voll modular sind alle das ist das ist hier 80 plus platinum 219 euro sind 215 volt keckel
und die testen das damit weil guck mal das hat 230 volt platinum ja top
ansonsten ach die haben zehn jahre garantie deswegen sind die so teuer aber das doch brauche
ich eh net so lange habe ich das netzteil noch gar net na doch vielleicht
atx 2.52 2.51 2.4 was zum was was was wollt ihr von mir besonderheiten elp lot 6 oder meinen
die lot also löt lötzinn oder was übrigens danke für die subs ich habe bestimmt wieder
was übersehen leute sorry falsch was übersehen aber dankeschön für alles ab sich guckt mal
kurz nach habe ich nicht letzter war wichtig wichtiger subscript wichtige subscript am
netzteil würde ich nicht sparen naja man kann ja sparen solange man keinen vorteil sieht
von den anderen wie teuer war der netziger pc ja 2500 oder so das kostet jetzt das kostet
eher 3000 irgendwie 3000 es war damals 1080 ti die war auch nicht billig ja auch muss
ich ja einrechnen die habe ich damals von von nvidia gekriegt aber die muss ja mit einrechnen
anzahl 12 volt schienen leute ich habe keine ahnung was das bedeutet was bedeutet anzahl
12 volt schienen
sind getrennte spannungsregler und braucht man das irgendwie
kannst dir mal sie sonic px
die sind doch
da jetzt der unterschied dazwischen das ist ein px 1300 und das ist ein platinium
prime ist das ist das was anderes
warum sind eigentlich die die produktbezeichnung so wir dass man das nicht versteht
ja 1000 das ist für die musik besser
ok komm ich nehme jetzt einfach das teil hier oder
es muss ja nicht jetzt muss ja nicht jetzt entscheiden ich lasse es ich lasse es jetzt
einfach mal so wie es ist da können wir den link nämlich mal scheren
wobei den link scheren wir das nächste mal ich überlege mir echt noch was für netzteil
rein soll dass ist der aktuelle pc den ich habe genau der aktuelle pc hat achtung das
da drin ich meine nicht nicht so nicht so wirklich exakt mittlerweile mehr ssd ist mittlerweile
auch mehr ram ja petter noch tourlüfter
welche grafikkarte kommt in den neuen hier guck die da
platinium zertifiziert das habe ich nicht habe ich nicht sogar ein platinium zertifiziert
das was sind das für eins das habe ich in der aktuell drinnen guck mal 80 plus platinium
habe ich warum nehme ich nicht einfach das gleiche nur mit nur mit 1000 nur mit nur mit
1000 willst du nicht auf die rx auf die 7000 von einem die nö ich habe vorhin schon bestellt
hatte ich das ist anscheinend das neue gibt es das nur mit 1500 oder what the fuck warum
gibt es das nicht mit 1000 doch ich blicke da nicht mehr durch bei den ganzen bezeichnungen
hier das da das alte brauche ich nicht da einzubauen in den neun das bleibt im jetzigen
rechner drin ich kommt mir das ich kommt mir das mal in ruhe an ich weiß gar nicht zumindest
ich meine ich habe hier alles ram und netzteil kriege ich immer easy weil ich habe keinen
bock dass ich alle teile da habe und auf einmal kann ich nicht bauen weil mir ram und netzteil
fehlt lul ja vielleicht tut es auch 850 weiß ich mal gucken da muss man muss man schauen
aber es macht jetzt ja preislich auch kein all zu großen unterschied das einzige blöde
ist halt dass das ding im eidl so gut wie nix sieht und netzteile halt bei geringer auslastung
in ziemlich schlechten wirkungsgrad haben die letzte amd karte ist eine gute frage
du meinst gar nicht mich aber ich kann trotzdem darauf antworten die letzte amd karte hatte
ich bei meinem vorletzten rechner am anfang guck dir mal hier bei meinem vorletzten rechner
nein das ist nicht das richtige das richtige video ähm tja man findet ja mal wieder nix
auf youtube also dem rechner davor hatte ich neuer rechner mein neuer rechner was ist drinne
da hatte ich eine amd karte drinne vor neun jahren und zwar eine asus radion hd 7079 matrix
platinium edition aktiv pci express 3.0 mal 16 retail muss man korrekt sein die hatte
ich aber nicht lang es ist ein bisschen näher ja die hatte ich aber nicht lang weil danach
hatte ich damals von nvidia relativ schnell eine gtx 89 bekommen die hatte den geilsten
namen hier gtx 980 ichil genau das ding das ding hatte ich damals die eno 3d geforce gtx
980 ichil x4 airboss ultra best bester name aller zeiten based airboss und da wurde die
amd karte relativ schnell drüber abgelöst also ich weiß nicht wie es mit amd aktuell
aussieht aber es wird anscheinend eine 490 erstmal wie gesagt beim netzteil bin ich mir
doch nicht sicher da müssen wir mal gucken ich weiß es nicht weiß es nicht wobei das
ist doch platinium raided warum nehme ich nicht einfach das was ich schon hinzugefügt
habe leute sagt mir das mal schnell warum soll ich andere setzer nehmen warum soll ich nicht
einfach das nehmen was ich schon hinzugefügt habe loaded
be quiet psu calculator ja die die die kalkulierten doch eher zu viel als zu wenig oder ok probier
das mal aus bitte auswählen intel sockell da ok übertakt erst mal nicht das einzige
was ich mache ist multi multi core enhancement oder wie das heißt dass die kerne alle auf
die maximale frequenz hoch dann eine hersteller nvidia 40 90 übertakt ein bisschen ohne usb
3.0 gen 2 wird zur stromübertragung verwendet nein einmal sata einmal ssd kühlung wasserkühlung
einmal pumpe einmal lüfter ermitteln ermitteln ähm was ist der unterschied zwischen ok was
ok moment wait a minute was pure power straight power dark power habe ich ram vergessen anzugeben
ah moment ne wo kann man den rammer ich meine nicht dass der ram irgendwas am netzteil wirklich
großartig ändern würde aber rechts oben ach da ach so das macht es jetzt da jetzt
wirklich fett oder ok was ist der unterschied zwischen pure power straight power und dark
power für mich sieht es ehrlich gesagt so aus sind es zwei sind es alles dreimal exakt
die gleichen netzteile aber anscheinend nicht ah das ist gold
unglaublich wir produkt zum vergleichen was funktions cookies sind nicht gesetzt ja ok
und wie setze ich funktions cookies muss ich muss ich mein blok ausmachen dass ich ok ok
es nun ok jetzt für gleich alles klar und dauereistung spitzenleistung ja wie nuktes
an der stelle form faktor zwei punkten form faktor e ps 12 volt ich weiß nicht einmal
was das bedeuten soll kabel management haben saal topologie full bridge rectifier ok da
wäre electro boom stolz auf uns endlich ein full bridge rectifier ok also ich ich lese
daraus moment also ich lese daraus dass das ding hier irgendwie laut piqua jetzt geilste
ist bei kibel hat jemand den shop kenn ich nicht hatte ich schon mal bei kibel bestellt
was hat was hat amazon für einen preis da gerade amazon warum ist amazon immer so ab
teuer bei so komponenten ich mein ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok
ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok ok
o kluge punkt was o kluge punkt habe ich noch nie was von gehört
ok aus wie ganz normaler shop heute habt ihr schon mal was von o kluge gehört ich
wirklich habe vielleicht habe ich ja sogar schon mal bestellt aber also ich
wüsste es ich wüsste es jetzt zumindest nicht o kluge selbes shop template wie
hardware rad ähnlich aber ja ähnlich ne das schon ein bisschen was anderes
wobei letztendlich unter der haube was ist es denn shopify oder was was haben
wir da ok da findet man das gar nicht o kluge das ist einer der größten
wichtigsten deutsch ernsthaft aber ich keine ahnung hab davon o kluge
hat das hat das ein 12 volt power connector nee oder 12 volt wie heißt das ding 12 volt
hrv pwr oder irgendwie sowas nee 12 pwr hrv oder irgendwie sowas soll ich mir
lieber nach 16 16 16 pinn suchen
nee haben sie nicht ok ok der chat weiß wieder 12 volt hrv pwr ok
ach stimmt da muss man noch einen dabei kaufen als ernsthaft ok wartet mal wie
quiet muss ich wirklich noch adaptat 39 euro für den fucking kabel beim netzteil was
240 euro kostet 260 euro seitens wahnsinns alter sind die sind die total
behämmert im kopf scam alda massiv massiv scam doch doch ein video liefert
das mit ganz ehrlich über adapter tut es auch ist mir ist mir doch egal
ja vielleicht nehme ich einfach dass hier ungut ist und dann ist ruhe dann ist ruhe
war geil 22 ich bin aber ganz im ernst was ist der vorteil wenn man den adapter
richtig rein steckt doch alles gut die sind abgefackelt zum größten teil weil
die leute die kabel nicht richtig reingesteckt haben
gachi bus holst du dir auch den rechten winkel von kabel mod was nö was soll
denn der rechte winkel von kabel mod sein poste mal was poste mal was was schon ich
wusste gar nicht dass man rechte winkel verkaufen kann ich dachte die kann jeder
selbst machen und es gibt auch leute die verkaufen
lipro officer kann man rechte winkel verkaufen und ist doch das was ich gerade auf hab dass
du den blöden kap nicht zu sehr knickst naja ja ich guck mal ich guck mal wegen
netzteil ich wie gesagt ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher ich lasse ich lasse es jetzt erst
mal so das habe ich digital ausschleicht auch gehabt
ja nee keine ahnung ja übrigens soll ich euch noch mal was neues erzählen und zwar
sekunde ich muss mal kurz hier meine vorschau besser platzieren
oh ich wollte heute eigentlich eine neue version vom fiat champ pushen wo hast du das gehäuse
bestellt bei amazon tatsächlich es hat irgendwie nur fünf euro mehr gekostet und soll angeblich
nächste woche irgendwie dienstag ankommen aber amazon mashify 2 xl moment moment nee der
stimmt nicht sekunde sekunde sekunde sekunde ich glaube das habe ich ich bin mir jetzt
gar nicht sicher da muss ich mal im handy quipper kann auch sein dass ich da was bestellt
haben habe ich hier das gehäuse bestellt
nee habe ich dann war mal zum bestellt nun della dankeschön für den sub nee du hast
gar kein zapp null erste nachricht keck wey das ist komplett verkackt wieder schön dass
dann wie ich ja gefunden hast kabel mod engels ok
cable mod zwölfer engel engelt adapters ist das irgendein 3d gedrucktes teil oder
ach das ist dass die leute die kabel nicht jetzt mal eine blöde blöde frage also auf
der seite sind die pc express stecker und ich stecke es von der seite rein von der anderen
seite rein da ist doch genug platz ach das ist weil manche leute quasi an die grenze
kommen von ihrem gehäuse und das dann da rausguckt nee sowas brauche ich nicht ja hier guck
da hier habe ich das hier habe ich das bestellt ich glaube ich glaube hier 12 bis 14 das ist
mir letztendlich egal das ist nächste woche montag wann das kommt vollkommen in ordnung
bora computer nähe da habe ich nichts bestellt aber kurz lass mal kurz checken pc king muss
mal kurz gucken guck mal guck mal kurz moment amazon muss die amazon app aufmachen man kann
ich es euch sagen ob ich es bei amazon bestellt habe oder nicht ja ich habe es bei amazon
bestellt arriving 13 december also nächste woche dienstag ja das reicht ja noch nächste
woche dienstag ich meine ich kann den kram ja zur not im stream habs was haben wir hier
gemacht oh nee nee nee heute nicht please gibt es da teil 3 von das fand ich so lustig
wir müssen uns teil gibt's gibt's best of gibt's best of bahn 3 das fand ich lustig
ich will best of bahn 3 gucken nee anscheinend nicht gibt's gibt nicht best of bahn 3 das
gehäuse ist mega fett gibt's denn schön viel rgb im neuen pc naja kannst du angucken also
es gibt nein die gibt es aktuell nicht wunschlisten omega lull also es gibt rgb ram wieso kommt
ein gartenvideo ständig hoch in den video empfehlung ich hab keine ahnung das weiß
nur der youtube algoritmus niemand weiß das niemand weiß warum
niemand versteht's also es gibt rgb auf dem ram es gibt rgb auf der grafikkarte und es
gibt rgb auf dem mainboard also ursprüngliche idee war ja scheiß auf rgb ich gucke da eh
nicht rein so und deswegen wollte ich eigentlich ganz ohne rgb bauen dann habe ich geguckt
als ich den pc zusammengestellt habe festgestellt aha der ram hat wahrscheinlich rgb die grafikkarte
hat rgb das mainboard hat rgb und für die wasserkühlung kostet die rgb version 5 euro
mehr als die nicht rgb version also habe ich einfach mal die rgb version gekauft hab jetzt
rgb ich werde es wahrscheinlich nicht großartig benutzen weil ich den rechner eh nicht sichtbar
neben mir stehen habe neben dem anderen rechner ich kann da gar nicht reingucken aber rgb
hauptsache rgb mehr fps wie viele lüfter hat das mashify standardmäßig hast du zwei
lüfter vorne und ein lüfter hinten du kannst glaube ich noch theoretisch zwei stück unten
reinbauen wenn du willst ja also du hast hinten einen lüfter vorne zwei lüfter und du kannst
glaube ich unten noch ich glaube du kannst sogar bis zu drei stück unten reinbauen wenn
du willst die sind nicht crap die gehäuse lüfter die sind durchaus in ordnung die fractal
design gehäuse lüfter hast du schon einen cpu köpftool nein habe ich nicht ich werde
meine cpu auch nicht köpfen die sind ganz safe crap hast du schon ausprobiert also ich
hatte die letzten drei pc generationen fractal design gehäuse und die waren alle ok und
ich musste sie nirgendswo austauschen das sind die billigsten hast du es mal ausprobiert
also ich habe mir tests von dem gehäuse durch gelesen die sagen alle lautstärke der lüfter
ist absolut ok und ich hatte die letzten drei pc generationen nur fractal design gehäuse
und die lüfter waren alle in ordnung alles im bereich das ich nie das bedürfnis verspürt
habe es auszutauschen ok wenn es nicht die lautstärke ist was was ist denn für dich
denn sonst crap an dem lüfter ich meine der lüfter dreht sich die luft rein und nicht
wo davon wieder auch kommen legt ein schratt nix also du kannst also standardmäßig zwei
lüfter vorne ein lüfter hinten dabei bei meiner bestückung wird es dann folgendermaßen
aussehen hier oben kommen ja quasi noch mal 3 140 millimeter lüfter rein von der warte
also hier oben kommen ja quasi noch mal 3 140 millimeter lüfter rein mit von der von
der wasserkühlung die ziehen dann aber raus die pusten die lufte raus oder ja die lufte
raus die lufte raus oder ja so
So
Es sind keine frames gedroppt
So die zwei vorne ziehen die lufte rein der hintere
Pläst die luft raus wobei es halt vielleicht sogar vielleicht brauchen wir den hinteren gar nicht
Eventuell mache ich unten noch welche rein das schöne ist dass die überall staubfilter haben dass sie nicht laufen was sauber machen muss oben
Staubfilter vorne staubfilter hinten unten staubfilter
hinten kein staubfilter weil hinten sollst du ja raus pusten
Der
Durchsatz plus die drehzahl reicht nicht für die abwärme von meinem system ach so warum nicht
Ich meine die grafikkarte hat einen eigenen hat einen lüfter die
Wasserkühler einen lüfter und zwei die vorne rein ziehen warum sollte das nicht reichen
Man kann theoretisch drei stück vorne hin machen oder noch mal zwei stück unten
Jetzt werden wir mal sehen ob das nicht reicht
Bin ich mal gespannt ich glaube nicht dass es da irgendwelche probleme gibt
Aber das probieren wir zusammen aus wenn ich das dann nächste woche oder übernächste woche wenn wir das dann zusammen
Basteln im stream
Das war abwarten ich mache mit da mache ich mir zu keine gedanken drüber ob das vielleicht die lüfter nicht reichen
Und selbst wenn die lüfter nicht reichen ist es ja überhaupt kein ding
Da kommen einfach noch zwei lüfter rein
Und jetzt kommt die lüfter rein
Und selbst wenn die lüfter nicht reichen ist es ja überhaupt kein ding da kommen einfach noch zwei lüfter rein
Man kann es nach von ab gesehn
Das gehäuse hat ja relativ viel kann er viel luft reinströmen auch so noch
also ich bin mal gespannt so was wollte ich euch da noch erzählen eigentlich wollte ich
was ganz was anderes sagen wo bin ich denn hier stehen geblieben leute haben wir irgendwelche
questions ja also ihr rgb gibt es gibt es habe ich dir jetzt gezeigt rgb gibt es im pc wollte
ich eigentlich nicht haben aber für fünf euro auf preis nehme ich auch rgb was ist hier motge
dis oder was wir wissen doch dass die problemik große mit sich nicht kennt dazu fällt mir bloß
ein moment das müsste ich war ins meme board mit aufnehmen nice cock das ist so dumm
also was habe ich hier übersehen was das für spooky musik
was hältst du von der logitech kraft tastatur kenne ich nicht
ok nix was nur nee das sieht nichts aus also das sieht nicht wie was aus was ich verwenden
will bei den tasten dass die rund sind würde ich schon anfälle kriegen dann sind die tasten
flach das mag ich beispielsweise überhaupt nicht deswegen komme ich auch mit notebook
tastatur nicht klar nee was ist denn der knubbel da oben zum scrollen oder was nee ehrlich
gesehen nee also weiß nicht also mein meins wäre es nicht ich habe auch eine logitech
tastatur aber eine mit ganz normalen tasten und normalen großen tasten und vierkicken
tasten so ich habe eine g was habe ich denn muss man kurz drauf gucken eine g 512 carbon
ig x roma roma broma ich erkenne es dann richtig was da unten drauf steht das ist so
eine fake mich das ist keine richtige mechanische tastatur soweit ich das in erinnerung habe
das ist eine fake mechanische tastatur aber ich mag die switches oder sind ja keine
switches glaube ich gar keine switches na ich mag aber das tasten gefühl von dem ding
es ist eine gute ist eine gute hybridsache für gaming und programmier stels auf der
arbeit habe ich nur ducky one skyline die finde ich massive prog allerdings mit numblock
chat numblock oder kein numblock ich bin auf jeden fall team numblock ja habe ich auch
lieber wenn du überdruck im gehäuse hast kriegst du keinen staub rein das wäre mir
auch lieber numblock wir können wenn ihr wollt modg mod check wenn ihr eine umfrage wollt
können wir eine umfrage machen numblock versus kein numblock ich mag numblock und das wichtigste
am numblock ist dass ich gerne ich haue gerne auf die enter-taste vom numblock ich schicke
gerne command line befehle ab mit der enter-taste vom numblock ja numblock ich brauche numblock
ich kann aber nicht abstimmen weil ich eingeloggt bin lull mega lull ja ich stimme jetzt einfach
mal selbst mit ab ich habe selbst mit abgestimmt auf der anderen seite also die meisten mögen
numblock ausrufe zeichnen pc ich glaube das noch der alte link ich kann es dir aber zeigen
rolling edelstein ich habe sie gerade noch auf wunschlisten omega lull das hier ist die
zusammenstellung ich habe alles schon bestellt bis auf ram und netzteil das netzteil wird
es wahrscheinlich auch nicht alles bestellt heute also 2 terabyte ssd nvme ssd den dcpu
btw wisst ihr warum ich mir die cpu geholt habe ratet mal wisst ihr wisst bestimmt ihr
kennt mich was ist mein use case für diese cpu habe ich überhaupt einen use case für
die cpu nein habe ich nicht der einzige grund warum ich mir die cpu gekauft habe ist weil
ich es haben will ansonsten wird es ein 13.700 locker tun ich meine es ist ganz cool fürs
rendern es ist auch ganz nice für was weiß ich viele vms und so aber die sechs mehr
low low performance course da die machen es jetzt auch nicht fett also numblock hat gewonnen
mit 76 prozent also das ist drin hier 2 terabyte nvme ssd 13.900k 64g ram 4090 grafikarte mainboards
da bin ich mir noch nicht sicher aber why not fractal design mashify 2 xl und ne wasserkühlung
mit 3 x 140 mm lüfter netzteil steht noch nicht genau fest
du hättest gerne in 13.370k gehabt das ist aber kein keine cpu oder das ist irgendwas
anderes was sagt denn was sagt denn hier ebay was ist das ein miniaturzug alles klar
meint er das ja ich könnte könnte mir nicht ferner liegen steuerberater zu sein aber ich
schwör auf numblock numblock beste
numblock overrated outdated gebated ja für dich vielleicht für mich nicht für mich
ist numblock essenziell klar naja beim video rendern ist es egal ob da effekte drin sind
h264 encodung lässt sich wunderbar multithreaden warum ist das gehäuse so teuer weil es extrem
hätt ist und mit fett meine ich jetzt nicht extrem gut das ist es auch für den anwendungstag
es ist einfach extrem fett hättige ist das guck mal das ist wo stehen die abmaße dabei
abmaße ja 24 cm mal 56 oder mal 57 cm mal 60 cm das ist ein riesen fettes ding schau
dir mal die preisentwicklung an kackel naja ja ja ja alles teurer geworden jolo also das
ist riesengroß das ding ich meine das gehäuse wiegt 14 kilo muss man sich mal vor den 14
kilo für den gehäuse leeres gehäuse 14 kilo da kannst du trainieren mit so zumindest
ich bin schon extrem auf zusammenbauen richtiger chunker ist das ja massive chunker was wiegt
der rechner am ende war schwer zu sagen also die wasserkühlung wird ein bisschen was wiegen
weil das einfach ein riesengroßes stück blech ist mit lüftern was wiegt denn so eine wasserkühlung
5 kilo wie viel wiegt denn das wie viel wie viel wiegt das ding 5 kilo oder so ich hab
keine ahnung gewicht steht da nicht gewicht ja 2 3 aber 3 ja so bis 3 kilo ich schütte
da gar nix rein schon fertig ok 3 kilo 3 kilo also 3 kilo die wasserkühlung die grafikkarte
was wiegt eine 40 90 rtx ich meine das ist die wird die ist zwar fett aber die wiegt
jetzt keine 4 kilo oder so die grafikkarte wiegt vielleicht 700 gramm oder what da steht
drinne bei geiz als bei der wasserkühlung dass die manche noch nicht das richtige montage
enthalten naja würde sagen würde sagen dann wiegt der rechner am ende so 22 kilo oder
so ungefähr so über den daumen gebeilt 22 kilo leichter als den drucker den ich mir
letztens gekauft habe der letzte sind drucker gekauft multifunktionsfarb laser weil ich
keinen bock mehr habe auf mein hintenstrahler der fuckt mich so ab nie geht er wenn ich ihn
brauche deswegen habe ich mir jetzt mal einen ordentlichen drucker gekauft den ich jetzt
bis zu meinem lebensende verwenden werde und der hat irgendwie auch 28 kilo oder so gewogen
aber das ding die treppe hoch ich meine 28 kilo ist an sich jetzt schon nicht das allerleichteste
aber das geht also normalerweise gehen 28 aber das ist so unglaublich eklig zu nehmen weil
das so fett ist nächste woche auf die waage stellen ja mit mir dabei also wisst ihr was
witzig ist wisst ihr wisst ihr was geiles wenn ich zusammen mit dem rechner auf der
waage stehe habe habe ich ungefähr so viel wie vor dem abnehmen wie letztes jahr letztes
jahr im december habe ich ohne rechner quasi ungefähr so viel gewogen wie jetzt mit rechner
auf also das was auf der waage steht letztes jahr december stand auf der waage ungefähr
das wenn ich alleine drauf stand versus heute mit mir plus rechner also wenn man von ausgeht
dass es ungefähr 18 19 kilo am ende wiegt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen mehr ich habe
ungefähr 18 kilo 18 halb oder so in dem dreh abgenommen also von 108,5 jetzt auf 90,8 oder
sowas und also ich wiege quasi das gleiche dann weiß der erste mal was du abgenommen
hast wenn du mit so einer fetten kiste auf der waage steht steht das gleiche wie vorher
drauf schon krass fühlt sich das geil an so viel leichter zu sein ja fühlt sich geil
an vor allem heute ich bin letztes gerannt zum zug stelle euch das mal vor ich bin gerannt
zum zug weil ich ein bisschen also mein zug nach würzburg ging keine ahnung 9 uhr 57
oder so und ich bin 9 uhr 54 aus dem auto ausgestiegen am hauptbahnhof und dann habe
ich den zug einfahren sehen und habe ich mir gedacht komm jetzt flitzt du mal und ohne
mist ich bin losgeflitzt und habe mir gedacht easy das geht ja total einfach und habe dann
extra noch mal noch mal gas gegeben ich habe quasi fast den kompletten bahnsteigen über
wo ich dann noch langlaufen beschleunigt das kannte ich gar nicht mehr es hat auch nicht
so sehr rum rum gewackelt bauchtechnisch und so ich konnte ohne probleme wieder richtig
richtig gut rennen und ich war danach auch gar nicht im arsch also ich bin quasi den
bahnsteig runter gerannt treppe runter rüber ich kann euch das ja mal zeigen gar noch maps
hauptbahnhof maps hauptbahnhof satellit ebenen poggers so ich bin hier ausgestiegen also
hier bin ich ausgestiegen hier hin und mein zug kam da also hier ist das kleis und mein
zug kam da der ist da eingefahren da bin ich da bin ich quasi also hier ich war so ungefähr
auf dieser höhe und da fährt fährt der zug an mir vorbei und hält dann irgendwie hier
so also bin ich dann quasi hier vorgeflitzt obwohl ne warte mal das stimmt gar nicht
hier also man doch hier das ist der gweg hier kann man eben dran vorbeilaufen ja so bin
ich da bin ich hier vorgeflitzt und man sieht das dann kann man runter das sieht von oben
ganz anders aus hier hier hier gehts runter hier gehts runter da bin ich rüber und dann
hier beim zug eingestiegen also das ist jetzt nicht super lang aber ich sag euch ehrlich
108 und 108 halb kilo hab ich mir schwer getan sowas durchzusprinten und jetzt easy ich war
danach noch nicht mal aus der puste und ich hab sogar noch mal gas gegeben auf auf der
mitte des des bahnsteigs also muss man echt sagen das war das erste mal dass ich gemerkt
hab dass ich das gelohnt hat also so also man muss ja sagen das abnehmen allein das abnehmen
allein ist jetzt nicht das was das alle also alleine gebracht hat sondern in kombination
mit dass ich täglich zwei stunden draußen unterwegs bin jetzt oder auch mal eineinhalb
stunden wenn es richtig beschissenes wetter ist aber heute wieder zwei stunden obwohl es
kein gutes wetter war also ich bin zwei stunden laufen draußen laufen nicht john laufen relativ
schnell wandern so durch berg und tal zwei stunden bewegen am tag draußen plus das
abnehmen das hat tatsächlich geführt dazu geführt dass ich ein bisschen besser rennen
kann wieder dass mir zum ersten mal aufgefallen jetzt als ich hier lang geflitzt bin ja und
wo es natürlich auch ein riesen unterschied ist zum beispiel wenn ich auf der erde rumkrabbel
und irgendwas machen muss ja letztens zum beispiel war ich im keller unten und hab wieder die
am ventil die die automatische regelung angeschlossen also ich hab ja am ventil so ein mal gezeigt
hab sp ja so was hier in der richtung blödsinn so was hier in der richtung habe ich da unten
habe ich unten im keller dran nur dass ich selbst den esp 32 da reingebaut habe und ich
den esp verwende ich habe quasi ein esp eingebaut hier drinnen mit das motor geflasht haben
wir das leute haben wir das nicht sogar im stream gemacht zusammen
haben wir das nicht haben wir das nicht sogar im stream zusammen gemacht wasser wasser
löten und reden haben wir das zusammen im stream gemacht
wasser soll man wasserrohr suchen wenn sich keiner von euch erinnern kann dann haben wir
das wahrscheinlich nicht im stream gemacht aber ich bilde mir ein wir haben das im stream
kaputt gemacht habe wirklich ach das ist wo ich den stream gelöscht habe weil ich dünnsches
hatte im stream kann das sein war das das wo ich dünnsches hatte ich glaube das war das
habe ich gelöscht hier ist morgen da ist es doch sicher dass es das war nee nee nee
nee nee nee das war das nicht oder ich erkenne nicht was wir in diesem stream sonst noch
so gemacht haben aber ich glaube das war was anderes keine ahnung zumindest ich weiß
nicht wie ich drauf gekommen bin aber ich habe unten so ein teil im keller selbst quasi
mit einem esp 32 ausgestattet mit das motor drauf und das kannst du über das motor remote
ein ausschalten dass sich das dreht und damit kann ich unten die wasserzufuhr für die heizung
im keller auf und zu machen und quasi den druck nachstellen so und irgendwie ist das
abgegangen da musste ich wieder so eine schelle drum machen dass das hält und da musste ich
auf der erde rum krabbeln im keller auf knien das wieder dran machen und ich hatte damit
ehrlich gesagt überhaupt keine probleme ich sag euch als ich 108,5 gewogen habe fand ich
anstrengend auf der erde rum zu krabbeln oder auch mit der katze irgendwas spielen also
überhaupt kein problem mehr also ich meine es ist wirklich also die 17 kilo unterschied
das ist wirklich extrem hätte ich nicht gedacht wenn ich mir jetzt vorstelle ich würde noch
mal zehn kilo weniger wiegen dann ist dann ist giga chat time angesagt
aber aktuell habe ich nicht mehr weiter abgenommen bei 91, irgendwas ist jetzt schluss aber ich
fress ja auch wieder massig in letzter zeit das habe ich übrigens die ganze zeit gemacht
also das war jetzt das erste mal dass ich wirklich richtig gemacht habe also ich habe
ich habe wirklich einfach mich viel mehr bewegt ein bisschen minimal weniger fettig gegessen
aber immer noch massen leute ich kann nicht ohne massig fressen existieren das geht nicht
ich muss immer richtig viel reinhauen ich muss so richtig druck auf den bauch haben
das schmerz jetzt bin ich satt das geht nicht anders kriegt es kriegt es sonst nicht hin
ich habe es ein paar mal probiert abzunehmen mit weniger essen das habe ich nicht lange
durchgehalten habe ich zwei drei wochen gemacht wenn es lange kommen ist auch mal ein bisschen
was abgenommen aber da ging es nicht so und jetzt einfach ordentlich fressen dafür ordentlich
bewegen easy eats probier es halt mal mit ohne essen wie ohne essen ist ja noch schlimmer
als weniger essen gut du meinst wahrscheinlich weil man sich daran gewöhnt aber ich ohne
essen alter ne ne ne ne ich brauch meine portion am tag hast du dir wirklich einen 40 90 geholt
jepp cock habe ich hier guck da 40 90 40 90 die da die hier
bewerb dich doch bei 7 vs wild was soll ich denn da ich will weder das eine noch das andere
das ist ungefähr so wie leute es geil fanden ins jungle camp zu gehen also kann ich verstehen
das wäre für mich eine bestrafung alter ich würde mich da im leben nicht bewerben für
welche 40 90 hast du genommen ja wie gesagt die hier die da aber hauptsächlich weil die
gullifa bei ist würde ich ja schon über jet gpt geredet ja aber heute nicht und ich weiß
ehrlich gesagt auf dem kopf gar nicht was ist irgendwas ai mäßiges
die rum chat wie macht man das mit der wasserkühlung eigentlich normalerweise hätte ich das alles
zusammengebaut und dann ins gehäuse geschraubt aber wie macht man das mit der wasserkühlung
schraubt man die zuerst ins gehäuse und dann macht man sie ans mainboard und dann baut
man das mainboard ein ja
auto killier cpu cooler ja das habe ich vorhin schon angefangen zu gucken war das der stream
ja genau alter wie der wie high iq mods das war der stream das ist der stream den ich
meine korrekt ruckels eigentlich gerade ist wo davon wieder im rumbacken ne geht ne ah
weiß ja nie das ist das stream den ich meine mods sind wieder richtig richtig massif iq
guck das ist das ding was ich gebaut habe hier da sieht man es ja dieses teil ja und
damit kann ich das ventil aufmachen im keller schaut mal sack
irgendwo sieht man es auch guck mal da hatte ich noch viel dickere finger sogar die finger
sind dünner geworden ja da haben wir das ausgelötet im stream
und dann habe ich kaputt ist das nicht das wo ich es kaputt gemacht ich habe das doch
kaputt gemacht oder habe ich das nicht geschrottet das ding
habe ich das nicht geschrottet aber kurz vorspulen ich glaube ich hatte das doch geschrottet
anscheinend hat es nicht funktioniert aber zumindest ich habe jetzt im keller noch funktioniert
wunderbar brick jam das ist nicht das wo es gesmoked hat ne das ist nicht das wo es
gesmoked hat da habe ich glaube ich irgendwie den motor verkantelt oder so oder das getriebe
irgendwie verkantet und dann war es kaputt naja wie groß bist du ich bin 174 also ich
bin immer noch zu dick mit 91 aber schon schon im sauber grünbereich
ich habe jeden tag ein pc mit rumgetragen ja und ganz schön fetten pc sogar
was hast du den pc geparkt wie gesagt habe ich ja gerade gezeigt jeder
keckel alter ich darf da gar nicht hingucken der december ist eh teuer erst vor zwei monaten
oder so neues auto gekauft jetzt den neuen pc da brauchen neue capture karte dann will
ich mir noch ein monitor kaufen ich brauche neues smartphone das wird teuer leute das
geht richtig ins geld wir haben inflationsausgleich bekommen ja 2500 euro bekomme ich inflationsausgleich
doppeltes gehalt weil weihnachten ist also ich denke ich kann mit meinem december gehalt
das bezahlen also zumindest den rechner kann ich bezahlen also den rechner kann ich locker
bezahlen wahrscheinlich kann ich anderen sachen auch noch bezahlen also ich müsste december
gehalt müsste ich lass mal überlegen december gehalt müsste ich ja fast 10.000 euro gekriegt
haben oder doppeltes gehalt doppeltes gehalt plus noch mal knapp 3000 euro 2500 euro ja
fast fast ja gut die inflations der inflationsausgleich da musste kein steuer drauf bezahlen also
die kommen auf dem konto an und ansonsten kommen weiß gar nicht wie viel genau ne nicht
ganz nicht ganz nicht ganz nicht ganz sagen wir 9000 wahrscheinlich ja 9000 ist realistischer
ja denke 9000 ist realistischer das könnte ein bisschen knapp werden aber davon kann
ich mit dem pc kaufen und ein smartphone und den capturecard und einen neuen monitor also
sprich mein december gehalt geht aber komplett drauf also zwei monatsgelder plus der inflationsausgleich
gehen quasi drauf für ausgaben im december aber das gute ist ja ich verdiene noch nebenbei
was und wer seinen primes ab nicht an besaß verschenken will und den auch frei hat ihr
müsst den natürlich nicht mir geben aber ich sag nur ihr solltet ihn nicht verfallen
lassen gibt es irgendeinem streamer den er gerne anguckt es hat schon gesagt dankeschön
für den sub gibt es irgendeinem streamer den er gerne anguckt ich freue mich natürlich
wenn ich ihn krieg ja aber lass sie nicht verfallen ist der sellout funktioniert immer
sample name null dankeschön für den sub easy ist jetzt schon sind wir schon mal wieder
ein bisschen näher an plus minus null im december dran
als glück gehabt aber ohne scheiß leute es geht mir gar nicht so sehr darum dass ich
den krieg ich freue mich natürlich wenn ich den kriege aber lasst ihn besser nicht verfallen
nico rock dankeschön für den sub real snx jetzt geht es zur sache dankeschön leute
ok zu verstehen geblieben ja ich weiß aber ich gehe mal davon aus nachdem es direkt
von akti cooling ist kommt es jetzt gleich ordentlich mit dem richtigen mounting kit
warum ist die musik so laut auf einmal was ist da los ja schon viel angenehmer
was ist dein lieblingsessen boah ich esse sehr vieles gern ich kann jetzt gar nicht
sagen also ich glaube ich esse wie jeder kerl gerne spagetti schnitzel mag ich auch gänse
braten oder sowas in der richtung ist eine tolle tolle geschichte sushi mag ich auch
gigabellen ich kann dir gar nicht sagen pizza wie gesagt asia zeug magisch indisches zeug
magisch türkisches zeug magisch deutsches zeug magisch ich kann dir gar nicht wirklich
sagen so was mein absolutes lieblingsessen ist keine ahnung müsste ich jetzt wirklich
überlegen ich esse ziemlich vieles gerne gewürz oder butterspekulat würde ich auch
beides essen macaroni größer spagetti das sind zwei unterschiedliche panoodle die man
für unterschiedliche sachen verwenden sollte du bist dabei einen rekt deinen rekord zu
brechen weiter so mit deiner unterstützung monka es das ist doch jebait wir hatten schon
mal level 5 sub train ist ab train nicht train das ist twitter twitch twitch jebaitet uns
leute die wollen dass ihr denkt jetzt noch eins ab jetzt noch eins ab dann haben wir es
geschafft so nach dem motto dabei ist es eigentlich überhaupt nichts mit rekord und mal ganz davon
abgesehen aber seriously was genau hat man davon wenn man den rekord schafft das ist
eigentlich so ziemlich das unsinnigste überhaupt es ist nicht so dass man sagen kann hui wir
haben den rekord geschafft heute ist ja ein richtiges highlight ja das habe ich vorher
angefangen zu gucken dass ich nichts kaputt mache ich wechsle ich wechsle ja da wollte
ich euch eigentlich nämlich was zu erzählen ja was was arbeitgeber wechsel angeht also
es ist es ist natürlich chat leute sekunde erzählt ich mache jetzt erst mal ich soll
noch mal kurz den chat durch weil ansonsten wird das wieder nix heute ich erzähle euch
gleich was zu so das stimmt schon gewichtheben mit der 40 90 rtx wie sieht es bei dir mit
weihnachtsgeschenke aus schenkst du deiner familie ja mache ich aber ich habe noch nix
gekauft noch gar nichts null bestellt welches auto hast du dir geholt das beste für mich
vorher hatte ich also mein altes auto war in grün das war mein altes auto massive agil
von 2001 du hattest das mein rot verkauft oder verschrottet verkauft so und jetzt habe
ich einen fiat 500 e 2021 2022 ja so ein hier ich glaube das 2021 mit alufelgen nicht dass
ich die wollte die sind dabei dieses teil habe ich jetzt moment innen genau jetzt habe
ich den full full e ja 3 plus 1 habe ich leute 3 plus 1 das ist beim einkaufen sehr praktisch
hinten und wenn doch mal einer hinten einsteigt ehrlich gesagt so wirklich gebraucht habe
ich die tür erst zweimal aber ist nice dass sie da ist ja und man konnte sich das glaube
ich sogar von innen anzeigen lassen hier gibt es anscheinend mal wieder keine gescheide
doch hier ne moment ich habe die fiat seite kaputt gemacht kann man sich die 3d angucken
jetzt oh leute fiat fiat rüstet auf was ist das für eine funktion jetzt naja gut naja
gut die funktion hat ehrlich gesagt keiner gebraucht wenn man ehrlich ist ja also das
teil und so sieht er halt aus was soll ich sagen ja und von innen von innen ist auch
sehr nice also von funktionen her von von freisprecheinrichtung bis die k play geschichte
hier unten kann man das handy reinlegen zum aufladen da muss man sich erst ein bisschen
dran gewöhnen das ist die gang schaltung quasi ja parken rückwärts und drive n habe
ich noch nie verwendet das ist so was wie leerlauf das ist wahrscheinlich wenn man in die waschanlage
oder so fährt der hat klar play ja wie gesagt ich habe so nie gebraucht n wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich jetzt wenn man in die war ich gehe davon aus dass braucht man wenn man
in so eine waschanlage fährt die ein wie nennt man das so da durchzieht wo man auf so eine
schiene fährt und und die einander durchzieht wahrscheinlich braucht man dann n für keine
ahnung habe ich nie gebraucht hier unten ist die handbremse was das die handbremse sieht
zwar nicht so aus aber es ist die handbremse braucht man aber nicht weil wenn man die drücken
los fährt geht die handbremse automatisch aus wasstraße ja so was in der richtung stimmt
wenn man abgeschleppt wird oder sich abstimmt ja hast recht gut anschieben bringt jetzt
beim elektroauto wenig vielleicht vielleicht ein stückchen auf schieben schieben da musste
auch auf n machen ja ja rückfahrkamera schildererkennungskamera vorne drinnen personendingserkennungskamera
wirklich nice und elektroauto fahren macht spaß wie groß bis 174 das geht es ist tatsächlich
größer als es auf den ersten blick aussieht also man kann da man kann er ohne probleme
drin sitzen ich denke mal wenn du zwei meter 9 bist oder so dann hast du probleme aber ich
passt da ohne probleme rein meine mutter passt auch ohne probleme rein anderer kerne hat auch
ohne probleme reingepasst und also ich merke noch nicht mal dass irgendwie die haare an
der decke kratzen oder so ist es ist kein problem ne sitzheizung habe ich nicht habe
keine sitzzeit so es heißt so keine keine sitzzeit so die heizung steuert man hier drüber
kann man einstellen das ding hat auch sprachbedienung also man kann auch quasi sagen heizung heizung
an man kann sogar sagen mir ist kalt dann geht die heizung an aber das ist blödsinnig
mache ich nie ich drücke einfach immer auf den autoknopf hier ist das was hast du gezahlt
mit deiner ausstattung also die ausstattung die ich habe gibt es so nicht direkt zu kaufen
das war nämlich ein vorführauto und der hatte bisschen spezialausstattung der hatte quasi
ein bisschen was von moment der hatte quasi zum größten teil die ausstattung von dem
großen aber nicht komplett alles genau da hat keine led scheinwerfer gehabt der rest
ist die der rest ist die ausstattung von dem ja da hat keine led stein irgendwie so was
glaube ich da hat keine led scheinwerfer und die rückbank ist nur zusammen und nicht getrennt
klappbar das ist das so also das das gibt so nicht zu kaufen das modell was ich habe
und was ich bezahlt habe ja ich würde es dir sagen ich weiß es gar nicht so genau ich
gucke aber mal auf twitter in meine private messages da habe ich das nämlich stehen irgendwo
ich glaube 22.500 23.500 oder irgendwie sowas 25.200 kann das sein 25.200 ich glaube 25.200
zumindest habe ich zumindest habe ich es in den twitter pms geschrieben wird wohl stimmen
jetzt fahre ich elektroauto naja neu kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten nee neu im
klassischen sinne dass der quasi in italien irgendwo in turin oder wo das ding gebaut
wird vom band gerollt ist und dann zu mir gefahren wurde dass nicht oder zu mir gekarrt
wurde mit dem lkw oder zu das nicht der hatte aber nur 7000 kilometer das ist also nicht
wirklich viel der wurde zugelassen im februar erst also erstes mal angemeldet im februar
glaube ich wurde der und ich habe ihn gekauft habe ich den gekauft leute im september glaube
oder noch august ich glaube september weil jetzt habe ich auch twitter twitter ist hier
eine lebensdokumentation ich habe doch da auto gekauft ok wann habe ich das gepostet
23 august alles klar also habe ich den jetzt quasi eins zwei drei dreieinhalb monate je
nachdem ich glaube ich habe den relativ ende august gekauft ja 23 august also dreieinhalb
monate und zugelassen wurde er zuerst am irgendwann im februar also im prinzip sagen wir mal
hier eins zwei drei vier ne manche habe ich verzählt oder eins zwei drei vier fünf
sechs sechs monate halbes jahr das ist in ordnung ganz im ernst neu und ohne prämie
für den preis würde ich mir das nicht kaufen das ding nicht rosa blau blau ist ja
feels bad man ja das ist gut ich kündige erst nachdem das weihnachtsgeld beziehungsweise
doppelte gehalt im december angekommen ist weil es ist so wenn und das ist anscheinend
gesetzlich auch in ordnung der arbeitgeber muss hier kein weihnachtsgeld bezahlen wenn
du quasi schon in so einem gekündigten status bist wenn die kündige erst am weihnachtsgeld
sechs monaten sieben kilometer ist 7000 kilometer ist aber kein normaler vorführe wagen ich
habe keine ahnung ob das normaler vorführe wagen ist ich kenne mich damit nicht aus warum
nicht warum ist es das nicht man sieht es zu viele kilometer oder oder zu wenige oder
zu kurz vom zeit ich habe echt keine ahnung hat bestimmt irgendeine mitarbeiter gefahren
ja kann auch sein sieben k in sechs monaten meint ihr ist zu viel ihr habt recht wahrscheinlich
ist gar nicht so viel drauf wahrscheinlich waren es gar keine 7000 kilometer ach was
weiß ich ist mir auch egal nice auto ja weil warum weißt du warum ich mir eine wasserkühlung
mit rgb gekauft habe weil die fünf euro teuer ist weil die fünf euro teurer ist als die
ohne rgb wie viel hat es jetzt moment ich kann ja in meine heim automatisierung gucken
jetzt hat das 7000 kilometer keck weight jetzt hat das 7000 kilometer ok ok also ich kann
es euch sagen also ich weiß jetzt jetzt hat das ding fast 7000 kilometer und gefahren
bin ich selbst schon 1944 kilometer also sagen wir mal hat es ungefähr 5000 kilometer gehabt
alles gekauft habe aber nicht viel unterschied oder bei 6 269 erstmal auto nicht mehr benutzen
ja das weihnachtsfest in meiner firma ist dieses jahr zum kurzzeit während der arbeitszeit
das ist richtig poge wenn es während der arbeitszeit wäre und ich geld dafür bekommen würde
würde ich vielleicht auch auf die weihnachtsfeier gehen ja danke schön leute an die ganzen
subs ich habe euch ja vorhin schon erwähnt aber wie sagen die wie sagen die ami streamer
immer da immer dann much appreciated brauchst du den pc on stream zusammen ja mache ich
ich habe mir extra eine maske gekauft mit kicks auf druck damit ich mich nicht selber
leake ja würde ich auch nicht machen lull habe ich aber gemacht also wenn ich flame
auf twitch kann man nachgucken wer ich bin auf amazon also twitch kann das ihr zum glück
nicht kannst du was zu meiner frage sagen die musste noch mal posten das finde ich jetzt
auf die schnelle nicht posten die noch mal mit wubblers dabei dass die gleich sehen
also wenn ich einer davon wäre dann der ist es nicht der dann am ende irgendwie noch
platt gewalzt wird oder so oder ist es der der platzt es ist das ist der der platzt
oder ewig her wo ich das geguckt habe muss ich auch sagen irgendwie irgendwie wirt film
fand ich jetzt nicht sonderlich dolle witzchamp
kennt ihr mal eine gute seite für elektron gs zum lernen ne kenne ich nicht aber elektron
gut manchmal kommt man nicht drum vorbei drum drum rum drum vorbei manchmal kommt man nicht
drum rum das ist die einfachste variante wenn man frontend sachen kennt und desktop anwendungen
bauen will covid maske oder richtige weder noch also es ist keine zugelassene covid maske
ist auch keine richtige maske es ist quasi ein tuch mit keks auf druck es hat so ein
fach für so eine ffp 2 filter aber den mache ich natürlich nicht rein wenn ich hier am
stream bin wir machen demnächst face cam stream leute nur dass ich keine face cam mit face
haben sondern ich ziehe dann die maske auf und wir testen ob die maske gescheit funktioniert
masken stream aber dann also ich macht jetzt macht die kamera kurz an und dann mache ich
wieder aus kicks kicks cam genau wieviel ich für den agila noch bekommen habe 600 euro
glaube ich und die haben ihn dann irgendwie für über 1000 weiterverkauft was das für
ein lied ist mario kart dulex
kleines auto weil stadtverkehr ja zum größten teil weil stadtverkehr ich meine ich fahre
ja nichts ja ich fahre zum wandern hier um die ecke mal irgendwo ein bisschen in die
berge oder in die land in die landschaft aber das sind das sind selten selten mehr als
irgendwie 50 kilo 50 60 kilometer wenn es hochkommt ja ansonsten fahre ich zum einkaufen
ich fahre mal zum bahnhof ich fahre mal zum doktor irgendwo hin in ein paket holen pakete
abgegeben also nichts will das also für mich ist das das beste auto
zumindest ist er sehr flott in der beschleunigung also ich muss echt sagen im vergleich zu
meinem agila gut ich meine im vergleich zu meinem agila ist alles schnell das ding hat
irgendwie 13 sekunden von 100 gebraucht oder sowas also wirklich wenn du mit dem agila
ein überholen wolltest du musstest du musstest quasi das gaspedal komplett quasi bis auf
die straße durchpressen dass du nebenbei vorbeigekommen bist und mit dem mit dem 500 e jetzt der hat
glaube ich ungefähr der braucht glaube ich ungefähr sieben sekunden von null auf 100
oder sieben sieben sieben halb sekunden von null auf 100 das ist jetzt nicht super krass
aber null auf 50 ist der mega schnell also null auf 50 ist wirklich du machst quasi
nichts du nimmst quasi fast nur den fuß von der bremse im endeffekt und schon bist
du bei 50 also auf 50 ist er irgendwie du merkst es gar nicht 50 und dann guckst du
den spiegel stellst fest moment war der kell nicht eben noch hinter mir und siehst du
dann irgendwie so gefüllt 300 meter hinter dir und ich sehe auch guck mal da und das
können die richtig fetten karren sein alter irgendwelche sei es bmw suvs irgendwelche
mercedes so die super fetten karren an der ampel also bis 50 70 bin ich weg ich mein
klar wenn es da länger grad ausgehen so sind die auch wieder am start zumal höchstgeschwindigkeit
140 damit fährst du halt so einem nicht weg aber beschleunigung ist schon nice und
da hat kaplay kaplay und da hat google auto heißt glaube ich ne android auto nicht google
auto android auto
was sagt man hey fiat ja du hast daran man sagt ernsthaft hey fiat wizard gamer dankeschön
für den sub man sagt ernsthaft hey fiat ich glaube man kann es auch zu den standard android
begriffen um ändern aber die fall ist hey fiat man kann dann sagen hey fiat mir ist
kalt zum beispiel und dann macht er die heizung an benutze ich aber nicht ihr wisst ich bin
kein voice assistant fern ich drücke dann einfach den autoknopf und dann gehts an
was soll mir dieser newsartikel sagen chat den newsartikel verstehe ich jetzt nicht
den jemand gepostet hat hier google ist eliminating the most easy excel version of android auto
ach so wenn man ein android tablet oder android telephone hat dass man dann quasi sich da
mit anderen drauf connecten kann mit android auto oder oder wie also dass ich quasi ein
smartphone als screen im auto verwenden könnte ja gut brauche ich nicht ich habe ja ich habe
ja den screen mit android auto unterstützung bzw ich verwende eka play weil ich aktuell
ein iphone habe den habe ich selbst komplett bezahlt ich habe es übrigens nicht bar bezahlt
ich habe es einfach überwiesen und dann musste ich noch mal meine bank anrufen da musste
ich eine email hinschicken an meine bank dass sie das überweisungs limit erhöhen für
den tag wusste ich gar nicht dass ich sowas habe so viel überweist normalerweise nicht
überweisungs limit erhöhen und dann musste ich das unterschreiben und dahin schicken
per mail also ich muss das quasi so die hatten mir ein formular geschickt das formular habe
ich ausgedruckt ich habe das unterschrieben dann habe ich wieder eingescannt und habe
es zurück per mail an die bank geschickt und dann hat die von der bank angerufen hat
gemeint ja ich habe gesehen sie haben das hier unterschrieben aber ich kenne doch ihre
unterschrift gar nicht und dann wollte die dass ich ihr meinen ausweis zeige habe ich
immer einen ausweis gezeigt und dann hat sie gemeint ja der ausweis ist abgelaufen ja ich
habe keinen gültigen ausweis gar also zu dem zeitpunkt ich hatte nur so ein übergangsweise
übergangsaus ausweis für drei monate habe ich nicht hat sie gemeint ja geht trotzdem
ok ging dann habe ich überwiesen da muss die musste auch angeben auf welches konto
ich das überweisen will auf der anderen seite ohne scheißleute es wirkt zwar etwas oldschool
mit ausdrucken unterschreiben einscannen aber ganz ehrlich besser als wenn zig leute
gescannt werden ich sage da gar nichts ist wirklich ist in ordnung ist in ordnung da
habe ich sie überwiesen sofort per sofort überweisung und so muss man auch extra anlocken
lassen dass man sofort überweisung machen kann weil das ist ja dann sofort weg kannst
du dann auch nicht sagen jetzt doch nicht ab buchen und so er kommt nicht so oft vor
dass irgendwie einer 25.000 euro über weiß also bei mir also ich zumindest ich habe kein
eigenheim in frankfurt warum die ist vor allem schnell vorführend dürfen ja wie gesagt
wir haben es ja neu ausgerechnet alles gut war anscheinend richtig
acht leute auf tiktok erzählen viel scheiße wenn der tag lang ist das kann man machen
aber ist es ernsthaft den stress wert willst du dir ernsthaft den stress geben dass die
dich kündigen wenn du easy einen neuen job kriegst war ganz davon abgesehen dass es
irgendwie assi ist vielleicht will man ja mit denen auch in so weit auseinander gehen
dass man irgendwann mal wieder arbeiten könnte und auf der anderen seite den juckts vor allem
will man sich wirklich den stress geben tiktok wird viel miss erzählt wenn der tag lang
ist also überall im internet wird viel miss erzählt wenn der tag lang ist aber wenn man
sich leute ich muss noch eine kündigung schreiben fällt mir gerade auf wie schreibt man sowas
am besten und ich muss mir den empfang quittieren lassen ich gehe da entweder diese oder nächste
woche also wenn ich bis ende der woche unterschrieben habe gehe ich da diese woche noch hin ansonsten
gehe ich nächste woche hin und gibt das ab was war der tiktok tipp der tiktok tipp ist
man sollte so die den arbeitgeber abfacken dass man gekündigt wird aber das ist der
stress überhaupt nicht wert wie viele akkuladung sind 700 kilometer naja sind wir mal großzügig
23 sehr großzügig kündigung per fax senden du wirst lachen da habe ich darüber nachgedacht
ob ich nicht per fax senden soll mal fax ist in deutschland mit sendebestätigung ja immer
noch akzeptiert wir wissen wie du aussiehst ja wie mein avatar hier auf twitch alles klar
hier wie wie wie keck bald sehe ich aus ok ernsthaft wenn ihr wenn ihr wissen wollt wie
ich aussehe guckt euch dens gaming an und dann mit mal gucken ob der aktuell viel oder
wenige haare hat ja also ich sehe ungefähr aus wobei der hat ein ganz schönes doppelkinn
mittlerweile wieder da gute denn also ich würde sagen ein bisschen dünner mittlerweile aber
ansonsten sehe ich doch ich habe mehr haare ich habe mehr haare ja aber ansonsten sehe
ich dens gaming relativ ähnlich
erbart mittlerweile hat er weniger haare als ich das ist nice das ist nice das ist nice
moment leute ich muss mal kurz twitter pns gucken ich habe was gekriegt private messages
zum teufel was wollen die
payment moment ich checke es gerade nicht was wollen die
ah ok nice ich kann es ich kann so jetzt mal kurz erzählen
samsung gekriegt ja also ich habe doch ich habe doch ein placement gemacht für so ein
mobile game und ihr habt es jetzt noch nicht bezahlt und haben sich erst mal drüber drüber
erzählt dass sie irgendwie weniger bezahlen wollen jetzt und haben wir gesagt wie ihr
wollt weniger bezahlen ich glaube sagt können ich einfach danach sagen nachdem wir alles
fertig gemacht haben wir weniger bezahlt und jetzt haben sie geschrieben ja überweisung
ist raus also alles gut hat sich hat sich geklärt
das habe ich auch noch nicht erlebt vorher also frage also wenn ich mir ein 13.600 kann
ich meinen ja kannst du kannst du machen der dh 15 oder dieser nocturne ist das ist ein
ziemlich guter das ist immer noch nach wie vor der beste der beste luftkühler also ein
der besten luftkühler kannst weiter benutzen ich bin mir nicht sicher ob er drauf passt
direkt oder man irgendwelche extra brackets braucht oder so das kann ich dir nicht sagen
aber vom lüfter her an sich wird er immer noch verbaut bei bei neuen pc also viele bauen
den noch ein bei neuen pc den kannst du weiter benutzen du darfst dich aber nicht wundern
wenn das ding unter benchmark voll lasst trotzdem an die an die als wie heißt das auf deutsch
an die tanz temperatur limit kommt das ist normal da musst du dir keine großen gedanken
machen und der gaming hat das ding dann am ende vielleicht irgendwie 70 grad gibt es
ist backliste für den neuen ja da fehlt aber noch das netzteil deswegen habe ich das noch
nicht geschert also im kurzen kann ich sich jetzt als das netzteil kommt da nicht rein
da kommt noch ein anderes netzteil rein rest kannst du hier angucken ja zwei terabyte ssd
der hier einfach weil es geht 64 g ram einfach weil es geht also ich habe schon alles bestellt
außer ram und netzteil außer ram und netzteil sehr schön ja das ist gut high IQ mods dass
er so eingestellt habe ja ist nintendo weihnachtsmusik aber wenn kein elektronische elektronische
was will man sonst aber da fällt mir mein wir haben früher im physikunterricht in der
schule so komische oldschool video aufnahmen geguckt von in so einem physiktyp und der
hat immer der hat immer gesagt elektron ich weiß ich vielleicht kennt ihr das gleich
wer wurde ihr dann in der schule auch schon mitgequält der hat der hat das immer so geil
ausgesprochen elektron aber physik vhs video so richtig so richtig schlecht aus dem fernseher
aufgenommen damals noch und von video abgespielt ich habe nix bei black friday bestellt also
was will man sonst nehmen außer elektron gs wpf sagt auch das ist richtig da gehts
recht hast du recht ja gebe ich gebe ich dir recht ich meine es mag für windows noch mit
das beste sein aber ich mag wpf auch nicht gibt es auch kein gescheites hatum man muss
fast ja man muss man als open source veröffentlicht man ja bei den lizenzen von cute da streiten
sich ja die geister drüber das kann ich jetzt abschließend auch nicht beantworten wie das
da geregelt ist ich glaube aber nicht dass du es auch muss machen muss das ist schwierig
das ist über dieses thema streiten sich ja viele leute ja maui ist auch müll also maui
ist ja der neueste shit was dort net ui angeht aber ich mag maui überhaupt nicht wpf ist
ja für windows only tatsächlich nicht verkehrt uwp kannst du knicken will keiner verwenden
also microsoft sagt man soll entweder maui verwenden beziehungsweise winui 3 oder aber
was ich dir empfehlen würde ist das da wenn du was mit dort net machen willst by the way
warum habe ich kein dark sieben an also wenn du was mit dort net machen willst würde ich
dir das dir empfehlen das ist quasi ein besseres cross platform wpf wenn man jetzt natürlich
xaml und das ganze zeug nicht mag dann ist das auch nichts aber das würde ich dir für
cross platform und dort net apps mal ins herz legen das anzugucken es ist kein offizielles
microsoft produkt weiß ich ob sich das abschreckt ja aber ansonsten wenn du gut dich mit frontend
die sachen auskennst ja elektron das stimmt wohl wir sind gamer dankeschön für den sub
benutze ich nicht habe ich mich noch nicht dran gewöhnt ich bremse noch und gebe gas
ganz normal ich habe mich noch nicht dran gewöhnt auf dieses automatische bremsen
sagt ihr atos was nö alles klar exzellent dass das wird sein
ja ich wollte wie gesagt ich habe es nicht vergessen dass ich euch noch was erzählen
wollte aber ich will erst mal den chat durch scrollen
einschreiben einwurf reicht völlig ich will das quittiert haben also mein plan ist folgender
ich lasse mir jetzt den arbeitsvertrag schicken der ist ja schon auf dem weg ich lese mir
den durch dann unterschreibe ich den beziehungsweise weiß man ja ob ich den dann schon unterschreibe
aber zumindest da gehe ich mit dem kollege mittagessen und gibt die kündigung ab weil
da bin ich in frankfurt dann bringe ich die kündigung bei der personalabteilung vorbei
und ich habe mir gedacht ich drücke das einfach zweimal aus und lasse mir das quittieren
auf einem der ausdrücke also erhalten am oder sowas da lasse ich mir das einfach unterschreiben
wenn ich da abgeben lasse twitch chat die kündigung schreiben da kommt natürlich sicherlich
etwas gutes bei raus wenn twitch chat meine kündigung schreibt sehr geehrter herr waller
ich bin weg genau das ist die beste kündigung also kündigung muss wahrscheinlich sinngemäß
sowas sein wie ich kündige zum nächsten möglichen zeitpunkt das ist der 31.12.2022
oder sowas in der richtung muss man wahrscheinlich eine kündigung reinschreiben ich nehme
ich nehme eine vorlage easy keck bei wir schreiben einfach keck bei drauf ja ich kündige keck
bei trau ich mich das aufzumachen
hey fax ist in deutschland wenn man sicherstellen will dass es ankommt wirklich nicht verkehrt
das gilt ja als beweis die quasi der sendebericht
keckel könnte ich noch reinschreiben unten drunter
ich kündige zum dings keckel keck bei und dann bin ich mal gespannt ob die es schaffen
mir ein zeugnis auszufüllen auszustellen gescheit weil ich warte beispielsweise auf mein aktuelles
zeugnis auch schon wieder drei drei oder dreieinhalb monate oder vier monate die kriegen
es nicht gebacken
der wird locker ausreichen ja
ich habe nix bei black friday deals gekauft nee ich habe jetzt einfach alles bestellt
cobalt comeback cobalt braucht kein comeback cobalt ist immer noch da cobalt wird nie weggehen
der cyberpunk ist jetzt ja nicht wirklich das mit der master dinge
fortleite ich mal wieder bock drauf das stimmt das stimmt
ich
wahrscheinlich dann da reinschreiben sehr geehrte damen und herren schreibe ich davon irgendwie
sowas ich suche mir eine vorlage und fertig open gpt sagt sehr geehrte frau herr also sehr
geehrte dahin hiermit kündige ich meine stelle als beim firmen zum was ne das würde ich nie so
nicht nehmen wichtig ist wichtig ist die zeit das ist das ist schnellst möglich machst wer
weiß vielleicht hast du dich ja verrechnet und die bestätigung brauche ich auf jeden fall auch
mcfly dankeschön für den sub ok leute ich habe es geschafft meine güter wie lange habe ich
den chat gepaart ok jetzt kann ich euch was erzählen also und zwar ich habe den neuen
arbeitsvertrag mehr oder weniger so gut wie schon vor vorliegen ja der ist gerade in der post und
jetzt über jetzt überschlagen sich so ein bisschen die ereignisse die letzten tage über also ich
hatte ja am freitag noch ein vorstellungsgespräch da mache ich aber ein video zu mehr content und
jetzt haben sich die letzten tage über leute noch gemeldet bei mir per mail und jetzt kommt
und es hat mir noch ein ex kollege der zufällig mein video geguckt hat am freitag abend eine
mail geschrieben ob ich nicht bei ihnen in der bank anfangen will ich sage jetzt die bank nicht ich
weiß wo er arbeitet ja beziehungsweise hat es mir geschrieben ich sags euch nicht in frankfurt bei
ihm bei der bank anfangen will mit sechsstelligem gehalt da bin ich jetzt natürlich auch prinzipiell
nicht abgeneigt allerdings sechsstelliges gehalt für fünf tage die woche fünf tage die woche
ja aber ich arbeite nur vier tage die woche also sind es dann weniger was ich hier mal geschickt
habe fragezeichen ich weiß nicht worauf sich das bezieht sag ich weiß nicht auf was ich das bezieht
die firma hattest du mir nicht dort net hattest du mir nicht hier nicht dort net entwicklungsstelle
gepostet mal oder war das jemand anderes nee kein dotnet entwickler
ja hat sie jetzt bei mir gemeldet per pn hat gemeint hier wenn du mir dein lebenslauf und
skill ist und so schickst kann es kann es einem chef weiterleiten ich habe mir die stellenanzeige
durchgelesen vorhin beziehungsweise ich habe mal geguckt bei denen auf der seite passt wie die
faust aufs auger wieder also tja naja willst du machen skill ist und dick pick natürlich was
sonst nice cock hast du jetzt schon einem anderen job zugesagt im prinzip schon das ist ja das
ding ich habe den anderen eigentlich jetzt schon zugesagt ich habe noch nix unterschrieben aber
es wäre schon also jetzt zu sagen mache ich doch nicht aber ich werde es mir ich werde es mir auf
jeden fall anhören was sie zu erzählen haben ganz ehrlich unterm strich gehe ich arbeiten weil
ich geld verdienen will und wenn es bei dem einen deutlich mehr gibt und der rest auch passt als
bei dem anderen dann gehe ich halt dahin das kommt nämlich auch dazu kabo oder die andere
seite würde es wahrscheinlich ehrlich machen wie gesagt überschlägt sich gerade aktuell ach ja
das war ja war ja noch nicht alles keckel habe ich ja ganz vergessen war noch nicht alles dann
hat noch kollege mit dem ich jetzt gerade noch zusammenarbeite hat mir erzählt er bewirbt sich
auch gerade woanders und die suchen auch noch leute die suchen auch noch leute ob ich einfach
mit ihm mitkommen will ich denke mir so weil er hätte euch das dann alles war vor zwei
monaten überlegen können man jetzt kommen sie alle von allen seiten aber im ernst leute unterm
strich ich suche mir einfach das beste raus moment das ist noch das noch geiler ist ich
habe eine zusage plus ich habe ja theoretisch noch einen job aktuell also wenn alle stricke
reißen kann ich immer noch sagen nope ich bleibe doch da einfach zwei stellen annehmen
und dann die krasse hast du hast du krank 80 stunden wochen machen ich meine das sind
dann 16 stunden am tag das kann man schon mal machen oder das schreiben die ganzen ceos auf
linkedin auch immer 16 stunden am tag easy das kannst du vergessen die wollen nicht habe
ich schon gemacht ich war ja nett ich habe meinem chef das gesagt bevor ich quasi mit
der kündigung die ecke kommen ich habe ihm das gesagt der hatte auch der hatte auch wir
hatten auch noch mal dann paar wochen später noch einen termin hat gesagt die firma irgendwie
bewegt sich dazu langsam und er versteht das voll und ganz dass ich weg will und was soll
ich dazu sagen ja hatte ich hatten wollten ich wollte nicht selbstständige energie zu
wenden ist auf keinen fall also prinzipiell hätte das natürlich seine vorteile ja ich
habe ja auch schon die ein oder anderen sachen mal nebenbei gemacht ja sei es von den tools
damals für hardware rat oder ich habe letztens beispielsweise auch für ein unserer mods für
die firma von ihm was was so ein prototype web anwendung gebaut immer auf nicht wahnsinnige
hoch euro beträge die da die da im spiel waren das waren keine wahnsinns aufträge über über
150.000 euro oder sonst was aber die ein oder anderen sachen habe ich schon gemacht das macht
auch unglaublich spaß wenn man dann einfach sich überlegen kann wie setzt man das um baut
es dann und dann funktioniert es und man merkt sogar die anderen freuen sich dass es funktioniert
und alles nice aber ganz ehrlich komplett wäre das nichts für mich ich habe beispielsweise
mal mit mit dem kolleg damals zusammen so einen prototyp gebaut wo man ruten planen konnte wo
handwerker ruten planen konnte ich weiß nicht was sie damit jetzt je gemacht haben konnte man
ruten planen in dem man beispielsweise eingibt heute müssen wir zu zu frau müller und hans
peter keckel und dann hat er dann quasi geplant wie du am besten fährst mit mit den terminen
und zeitfenstern und so war eigentlich auch nice das projekt also ich habe schon die ein oder
anderen sachen gemacht in der richtung aber selbstständig komplett will ich nicht sein
das ist einfach unglaublich stressig weil du musst dich halt um alles selber kümmern und wenn ich
mich um alles selber kümmern muss dann kann ich kein youtube und twitch mehr ordentlich nebenbei
machen deswegen ich will einen job haben wo ich weiß der laden ist morgen noch da und ich will
einen job haben wo ich nach acht stunden mich nicht mehr im kopf auf die arbeit konzentrieren
muss weil das ist die wichtige geschichte bei mir wenn ich acht stunden gearbeitet habe dann will
ich mich um youtube und twitch und sonstige sachen kümmern können und nicht nur an die arbeit denken
deswegen fallen zu kleine läden weg wo man quasi der einzige admin ist zum beispiel ja oder der
einzige der sich mit einem service auskennt weil dann ist man quasi zwar offiziell im feierabend
hat aber nie feierabend mensch ich glaube alter ich habe gerade ich habe gerade in die in die
mails geguckt ich habe noch eine mail bekommen arbeitgeber meine güte was wollen jetzt alle auf
einmal heute gar nicht mehr auf was hat er denn geschrieben ich gucke da besser nicht rein oder
wenn du ihn gebannt hast dann scheint es was scheint es was schlimmes gewesen zu sein
ach werbung ah so ok das ist meine nette mail das ist meine nette mal ich habe keine mail
bekommen ich dachte es geht darum irgendwelche job angebote nein mir hat ein mir hat jemand von
der personalabteilung geschrieben von einer also jemand der in der personalabteilung arbeitet
hat geschrieben hey max ich bin schon also sinngemäß hat er geschrieben er ist schon
irgendwie zehn jahre abonnent und vielleicht kann er sich irgendwie damit bedanken für die
ganzen videos dass wenn ich fragen habe wie irgendwie so eine personalabteilung tickt dann
soll ich ihn einfach anschreiben ja das mache ich mal gucken aber es ist übrigens mal eine nette
nett gemeinte mail ja ansonsten gibt es ja viel bullshit auf youtube aber es gibt auch nette
leute weiter soll ich euch mal ein schönes schönes kommen kommen zeigen was einer unter
die videos geschrieben hat habe ich gerade einen screenshot gefunden was wollte er mir sagen ich
habe gerade den screen ich habe gerade diesen screenshot gefunden auf dem zweiten rechner auf
dem desktop hat er bei mir unter video gefragt hat er mich gefragt hast du gerade geschrieben
dass du von irgendjemanden die mutter gefickt hast also nicht dass ich mich dran erinnern könnte
wie gesagt nicht dass ich mich dran erinnern konnte du warst bestimmt nicht der einzige
das ist wahrscheinlich im deutschsprachigen youtube youtube raum eines der häufigst geschriebenen
sachen auf youtube man ja so sieht es aus also habe ich euch habe ich euch auf einen aktuellen
stand gebracht jetzt wisst ihr bescheid mal gucken wie das wie das job technisch läuft
eigentlich habe ich mir jetzt ja schon dafür entschieden dass ich zu dem zu dem anderen laden
gehe ja welches der 200 pc ok komm einmal zeige ich noch hier darfst du die branche spoilern
ne mache ich nicht also 2 terabyte ssd 13.900k 64 g ram 4090 ein mainboard ein gehäuse eine
wasserkühlung und netzteil wo ich bin euch genau sicher bin was ich kaufen will da bin
ich bin noch nicht ganz sicher so eigentlich wollte ich jetzt auf aber gibt es noch irgendwas
was wir uns kurz angucken können java script for the haters become a full stack developer
ok ein full stack developer roadmap for beginners ok gibt sie gibt sie roadmap auch ohne gelaber
sondern einfach nur die roadmap hier infographics alles klar ok f da gucken wir uns jetzt auch
nicht an ne habe ich nicht haben wir uns gestern erst drüber unterhalten im stream der dark
mode vielleicht ist es tatsächlich dark mode Leute die die die seite sieht ein bisschen
nach scam aus ich mach die mal kurz hier auf hier geht sie ok full stack roadmap ich soll
die email adresse eingeben für eine full stack roadmap ihr könnt mich mal keckel ok was
sollen wir lernen full stack developer breakdown python postgres javascript typescript ok
alles klar was auch immer die musik
for reviews gucken noch nicht noch nicht erst mal rechner bauen und dann und dann schauen
was ich mir kaufe ich habe gesehen dass lg jetzt neuen oled vorgestellt hat den gibt
es bald zu kaufen wahrscheinlich 27 zoll ja den da das finde ich nice das finde ich nice
ja also hier ein oled monitor 27 zoll 100 440 p 240 herz oled eigentlich eine richtig
coole sache gibt es noch nicht aber das ist was da bin ich dabei perf will ich nicht
mk der kram ist teuer
also den habe ich aktuell ins auge gefasst wenn es den denn dann gibt du hast recht ich
werde mir auch nicht direkt einkaufen ja 43 zoll monitor ist mir viel zu groß für
den schreibtisch hier ja g-sync freesync open sync was auch immer alles gibt zynk ng
was was was sagt computer based dazu krass was lg macht von eiso hört man eiso habe
ich wirklich ewig nichts mehr gehört ich habe links ein iso monitor stehen schön kalibriert
rgb technisch aber den habe ich halt nur als vorschau monitor von gigabyte ja aber kein
oled oder ich habe ich habe aktuell auch ein 240 herz monitor aber das sein monitor ist
noch mal eine runde geiler gerade was kontrast angeht und und schallzeiten also das ist dann
quasi wirklich mehr oder weniger wie in den röhrenbildschirm von der geschwindigkeit
her
ne also da da schiel ich gerade ein bisschen drauf auf diesen monitor ansonsten abwarten
was sich das jahr über noch so entwickelt ja wollen wir noch irgendwas gucken jetzt
zeigt mal was können wir uns denn anschauen sind mal
jetzt nichts dabei was ich mir angucken will also zumindest jetzt nicht ach es gab einen
neuen 16 star world record oder speedrun das gucke ich immer gerne hier 616 star world record
suigi das ist das hier fast vor drei tagen moment dann ist das hier gar nicht mehr der
world record weil da ist schon vier vier monate vier monate ja 1441 und das ist noch
1443 gewesen krass die tippe sind so heftig drauf komm wir gucken uns noch an warum ist
der anlistet das guckt leute das gucken wir uns jetzt noch moment hat er das nicht hat
er das nicht in irgendeinem live stream erspielt oder so ne hat er nicht egal komm wir gucken
uns noch den neuen speed speed world record an noch gucke ich immer gerne mal zur abwechslung
mal kurz die musik ausmachen hallo man die quali sagt halt warum ist die quali na gut
was heißt die quali sagt das spiel ist halt einfach auf der auflösung aber das sind
auch keine splits und so das ist aber doof wenn da keine splits drin sind hier ist er
doch hier ist doch alles mit da ist es doch ein bisschen dunkel oder das ist auf dem
n64 erspielt da siehst du hier das ist auf auf auf auf dem japanischen n64 soweit ich
weiß ist 120 sterne auf dem ami n64 also ist die ntsc version die die englische west
ne auch nicht oder war das bei ocarina of time wo die einen japanische verwenden und
die anderen verwenden amerikanisch also das hat was mit den textboxen zu tun wie schnell
die textboxen sind manchmal sind die textbox in japanisch schneller manchmal auf englisch
je nachdem welche route du nimmst ich glaube bei mario 64 ist mehr oder weniger immer die
japanische
next gen graphics damals leute ich weiß doch ich habe echt gestaunt wo ich vom fernseh
gesetzt gesessen habe damals also als ich klein war und und das intro zum ersten mal
gesehen habe war ich wirklich sprachlos ja vor allem das movement war was noch nie da
gewesen ist und das man eins muss man sagen das spiel wenn das ist heute noch beliebt
ja also die müssen movement technisch was richtig gemacht haben dass das heute noch
heute spielen die grafik kann es nicht mehr sein jetzt erst mal long jump über die brücke
ohne dass lakitu kommt jetzt machen sie alle easy sonst wird direkt gesettet klappt das
nicht guck da steckt er im boden pass der anfang ist mega krass von diesen speedruns
da klitschen die hier immer durch durch wende durch ins bowser level ich hoffe das kommt
jetzt ja ja genau guckt euch das mal an guckt euch das mal an leute
ja und übrigens der grund warum die das ganz am anfang machen ist und es war davon
wieder am spinn
jetzt ich hoffe so kann ich ja der grund warum die soll diesen trick ganz am anfang
machen ist folgender der trick geht öfters mal schief und so verlierst du weniger zeit
und kannst natürlich setten wenn es schief geht aber es krass wie konsistent die das
hinbekommen mittlerweile wie schafft man sowas übung leute die haben was weiß ich 50.000
stunden super mario 64 von mir wenn du es von mir siehst dann sieht es nicht wie ein
speedrun aus sondern wie einer deshalb nicht kann
alter zu so ein krasser flow auch drin da ist nichts nichts überflüssig er
ok er rennt um die röhre drum herum das letzte mal glaube ich was ich gesehen habe war noch
dann wurde über die röhre gesprungen das ist wahrscheinlich 5 millisekunden schneller
alter hör ihr hört euch mal den stick an leute hört euch mal den stick an leute pass
auf hört ihr den stick der stick habt ihr nicht gehört den stick ok ok und
pass auf pass auf hört euch den stick an wie er den stick dreht jetzt jetzt gleich sobald
sobald der bowser fängt so jetzt jetzt pass auf jetzt wie er den analog stick dreht
jetzt das ist das ist analog stick dreht mit df alter der hat ihn irgendwie gerade mit mit
800 rpm gedreht oder so ist das
überhaupt die amerikaner die die japanische version war es nicht so dass in der japanischen
version bowser noch ein stern getropft hat anstatt einen schlüssel
ach nee die anzeige nach dem einsammeln des schlüssels ist da eine sterne und ansonsten
ansonsten glaube ich ein schlüssel in der us version
wohlgemerkt in 14 minuten ist das game durch
könnte den elektromotor sein ja
das hört sich so an könnte ein elektromotor sein richtig koggers
wieviel views hatten das warum hatten das nur so wenig views
aber normalen controller verwendet viele verwenden gamecube controller aber nach dem
sind n64 jetzt hat er wahrscheinlich n64 controller dran also ich weiß dass in vielen speedrun
games gamecube controller recht beliebt sind aber in dem fall kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
das wird wahrscheinlich n64 controller sein an einem n64
die haben so krasses movement die leute das sieht so einfach aus aber probiert das mal
ich habe es nie probiert ich habe aber leute gesehen die es versucht haben zu üben dieses
rückwärts da reinspringen in den käfig das ist nicht so ohne nicht so ohne
ja der n64 controller hat keine runden analog stick sondern er hat so eine eckige fassung
ja ja deswegen hört sich das auch schneller an als man es bei der runden denken würde
ja aber trotzdem hat er das saumäßig schnell gedreht
jeder movement fade ist instant reset guck mal wie wenig zeit er noch sparen kann hier
gerade eigentlich leckte ich was right about being out of wamps i literally said that i
this one was getting out of wamps they call me the wamps getter outer of her pretty crazy
was ach ja übrigens das ist auch neu weiß ich ob ihr das schon kennt ich verfolge die
diese ich gucke mir regelmäßig speedruns an das ist auch ein neuer trick den gibt es
erst seit einem jahr oder so dass man hier über die über die dünen boosten kann und
das sieht so einfach aus leute ich habe ein stream gesehen wo das einer versucht hat zu
üben und das ist kein schlechter runner gewesen er hat nicht konsistent hinbekommen also das
hier jetzt dieses dieses weiß gar nicht wie man diesen sprung nennt dieses wora so mit
dem bein nach vorne springt guck der verliert mario verliert jetzt kein speed an der stelle
das sorgt dafür dass man jetzt den stern hier oben von diesem vogel direkt bei der
ersten ich zeige es euch so hier den stern kann man jetzt bei der ersten säule einsammeln
dadurch dass man über den über den über den sand gesleitet ist und zwar quasi über
den sand klitsch gesleitet ist dass man schneller ist sonst könnte man nämlich den stern von
dem vogel nicht mal nicht mal bekommen auf der ersten säule ruckler oder input lag
ja ist instant reset dann klappt klappt nicht wenn das ruckelt oder so ist vorbei aber nach
dem der ja kein betriebssystem drauf läuft beziehungsweise keine garbage collection rund
oder sowas das läuft relativ konsistent würde ich sagen ja alles klar alles klar alles klar
übrigens auch irgendwelche dudes haben mal festgestellt dass es schneller ist da rein
zu klitschen den stern drin zu sammeln wie irgendwie die sterne draußen zusammen auch
ne leckt es wieder ne leckt nix hier ist kein leck alles perfekt so das ist noch mal die
pyramide oder ja genau noch mal der pyramiden stern ich kenne die aktuelle route aus dem
kopf nicht ich glaube also entweder holt er sich jetzt hier noch einen oder er geht direkt
weiter zum feuer ja genau er geht weiter in ins lava lava land oder wie das wie die weiß
gar nicht wie die wie die stage heißt so dann wird jetzt gesurft gleich ne es werden die
genau es werden die die red coins geholt danach wird irgendwie dieser dieser stern mit der
cooper schell gemacht und zum schluss glaube ich noch dann den im vulkan also die cooper
jetzt kommt der stern mit der cooper schell dann kommt im vulkan glaube ich noch der eine
nie außen rechts oder außen rechts kommt noch einer außen rechts kommt noch einer
oder kommt doch direkt der vulkan ok anscheinend mal gucken mal gucken das meist ist in c geschrieben
ja leute guckt euch mal ohne scheiß hätte irgendjemand dieses level früher so gespielt
da musst du außen rum mit dieser komischen fahrstuhl plattform und das ist übrigens
saumäßig schwer normalerweise stirbst du da wenn es nicht richtig richtig teilst dass
so krass alter er gut so sehen halt irgendwie 15.000 stunden mario 64 aus das ist wirklich
heftig man übt so speedruns gar nicht ich muss mal ein bisschen ein mit dem bettel viel
wieder üben pass mal auf ihr jetzt die treppe hochspringen guckt euch das mal an die haben
so das ist heftig ich habe wirklich schon viele mario 64 speedruns gesehen ja ich habe sogar
mal mir einen auf dem channel gezeigt mit thailo zusammen damals aber mich begeistert
das immer wieder obwohl ich schon einige geguckt habe seit jahren mit letzten jahre verteilt
hast du am wochenende keine nups gefangen doch eine runde 77 11 genau jetzt kommt noch
das wo man da drüberspringen muss ja ok da kommt danach das mit der cooper schell noch
weil es kommt jetzt noch es kommt jetzt hier noch ein stern dann kommt dann kommt die diese
nee kommt der cooper schell stern den macht man nicht mehr oder hat er den schon macht
man den gar nicht mehr macht man den nur bei 120 ok jetzt kommt wie heißt dieses dieses
das da wo es metall mario gibt normalerweise weiß gar nicht wie das level auf deutsch
heißt zumindest das mit den rollenden steinen ob es schon ich glaube es gab noch kein entwickler
reaktet auf mario 64 speedrun zu anderen gab es ja schon wenn ich habe ich glaube zu mario
64 noch nicht habe ich gesehen du du du du du du du du ich meine das spiel nahezu perfekt
oder ist trotzdem nur ein also mario 64 speedrun experten werden ich sag da hat er drei frames
verloren und so was aber für mich sieht das schon wirklich nahezu perfekt aus und es
hat wirklich nur 1,1 sekunden vor dem aktuellen weltrekord 1,1 sekunden obwohl er nahezu perfekt
spiel also sieht man wie optimiert das ist mittlerweile weil nicht so krass wie irgendwie
das erste mario wo du theoretisch nur noch maximal irgendwie keine ahnung fünf frames
sparen kannst oder so oh wait a minute war das echt ein fehler gerade auf der switch
auf der switch gab es diese 3d collection die aber ziemlich gesagt hat kawut es gibt
schon das gibt schon ai plays mario 64 jetzt hat er gleiche minus er gleich plus auf seinem
seinen split ich mein guck mal wenn er nur 1,1 sekunden jetzt voraus war kann man sich
vorstellen dass er doppelt anlauf nehmen musste für den sprung ist schon mal zwei drei sekunden
zeitverlust klingt für uns jetzt belanglos aber wenn man halt weltrekord speedrun haben
will ist das nicht belanglos sind dann drei sekunden schon viel was das habe ich noch
nie gesehen das lang slide da okay das war der letzte stern jetzt gehen wir zu dauer
docks nee ist das überhaupt ist das überhaupt dauer dauer docks ich glaube das ist dauer
dauer doch so genau da gibt es jetzt noch da genau da gibt es hier gibt es den den
16 stern gibt es im dauer dauer docks den stern hier braucht man nicht ach ja übrigens
wer sich jetzt fragt warum hat er überhaupt einen stern geholt und nimmt nicht diesen
stern hier mit auf den weg ganz einfach der hase spawn vorher nicht er spawn erst mal
15 alter what the fuck alter wie schnell er dauer durchkommt wtf normalerweise also in
den normalen strats die man da so benutzt die ich aus vom zugucken aus speedruns kenne
ist man krabbelt da halb rein dreht sich irgendwie rum krept den hase und geht dann
klitscht dann irgendwie rückwärts durch und das ist ja krass hier einfach durch die
tür geklitscht in 100 millisekunden würdest du die 30 70 noch kaufen ich jetzt nicht
ich nicht übrigens muss man auch sagen an der stelle gesagt habe ich die letzten jahre
über ein bisschen damit beschäftigt weil weil ich halt vieles geguckt habe also wenn
ihr euch zu viel laber sagt bescheid aber dieses schwimmen allein allein dieses schwimmen
ist nicht wie wir schwimmen würden den mario 64 das ist nahezu frame perfekt schwimmen
weil wenn du zur richtigen zeit den a knopf zum schwimmen drückst hast du mehr speed
guck hier dass der so schnell dass er so schnell schwimmen kann der muss exakt zum richtigen
zeitpunkt der animation von mario die schwimmbewegung drücken und einfach spammen die taste tut
nicht du musst exakt richtig die schwimmbewegung du musst exakt richtig den input drücken
zur schwimmbewegung dass du dieses schneller schwimmen aufrecht halten kannst normalerweise
bist du irgendwie ein viertel langsamer wenn du normal schwimmst also wenn wir das spielen
würden und schwimmen würden wir werden irgendwie ein viertel langsamer
ist auch nicht gedacht dass man da hoch kommt eigentlich rutscht man da runter ok das war
der letzte stern jetzt kommt bowser level 2 und ich glaube ich glaube ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher ich glaube wisst ihr wisst ihr was der grund ist warum er hier anzoomt mit
der kamera warum zoomt er hier an mit der kamera ist jemand 5 hat genug und weiß es
ich bin mir relativ sicher dass es so ist also es ist nicht dass er schlechter sieht
korrekt dass das spiel nicht ruckelt mehr fps dass das das spiel nicht ruckelt
the way to dank
alter krass meine güte
so jetzt können wir gleich mit der controller analog stick drehen hören
so achtung analog stick drehen jetzt please oh man
kogas
ok erstmal kurz hier ein bisschen
entspannungsübung gemacht
jetzt klitsche durch die wand ja so und jetzt kommt das wo die meisten runs erst mal probleme
bekommen wie gut er das hinkriegt leute das sieht easy aus das ist nicht easy vor allem
wie schnell er den a-knopf gesperren hat
so und jetzt gleich noch mal durch die tür klitschen beziehungsweise die treppe hoch
klitschen
übrigens ist auch nicht so einfach normalerweise kann es durchaus sein dass man das nicht richtig
trifft und dann irgendwie woanders durch fällt und so mich in den trigger rein so letztes
bowser level wir sind bei 13 minuten 31
ich vermute es der normale in 64 controller ja weil es ja auch noch mal wird das geht
alle guckt euch das mal an
man kann davon abspringen
ok alles klar
wisst ihr was ich krass finde dass immer noch neue strats gefunden werden in dem spiel
wo du das noch ein paar millisekunden schneller machen kannst
achtung jetzt noch ein paar mal koggers im kreis
wie gut er auch trifft das war früher bei den leuten immer so ein bisschen zitterpartie
ob die bowser würfe treffen oder nicht
das war knapp
er raste da aus
er hat nahezu perfekt gespielt hier war er bei plus minus null
krasse scheiße
als nächstes kommt dann zap 40
guckt euch mal der ist relativ jung ja man würde jetzt eigentlich erwarten mario 64
wer spielt mit keine ahnung wie alt er ist 19 oder so wer spielt mit 19 bitte schön
mario 64 aber da sieht man mal wie gut das spiel gealtert ist kann man nicht sagen aber
wie attraktiv das spiel heute immer noch ist für viele leute
zwei sekunden ist übelst viel ja man hat doch gesehen wie optimiert das ist wo willst
du hier noch groß zeit einsparen ich meine außer man findet neue wege
der controller hat feuer gefangen
krasse scheiß also der hat es durchgespielt aber richtig
warum hat das nicht mehr views mal normalerweise haben mario 64 world records irgendwie 1,5
millionen
halber nerven zusammenbruch jetzt aber kann man ja auch verstehen aber heftig oder
also
gg ohne itz weil es war alles andere als itz
gg itz ist es ja nur weil man multiplayer spiele spielt und knapp gewonnen hat umso
knapper man gewinnt umso mehr easy ist das
wie wir alle wissen
frame jobs wurde aufhören
first try klar immer first try und wins only first try
noch im vergleich den ai rein schauen ne ich geh jetzt ins bett gleich in halbe stunde
ja morgen bestelle ich noch den ram und das netzteil und dann ist der neue rechner auf
dem weg dann bauen wir den demnächst zusammen mal gucken was alles da ist weiß es nicht
vielleicht habe ich glück und zum wochenende oder halt nächstes wochenende
bauen wir dann den rechner
gucken wir mal leute
chat gpt ich muss mal ein bisschen ausprobieren dass da wirklich fundiert was zu sagen kann
soll ich jemand hosten
haben wir irgendjemand von denen denen ich folge die das
kleine channels denen ich folge die ich öfters gucke
der
Nö, glaub grad keiner da, der Siren spielt Kalisto Protokoll, den könnten wir hosten.
Komm, den hosten wir. Wir haben lange keinen gehostet. Könnt ihr mal Hallo sagen von mir,
ich komm nicht mit rüber. Ich geh jetzt gleich off, mach mich schon mal fertig für Betge.
Ja, und ansonsten Leute, wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich morgen schon wieder. Mal schauen,
wenn der Rechner da ist, wollen wir den Rechner zusammenbauen. Bis denn Leute, machts gut, see you.